the formal invasion of Gaza has begun
now the other day we saw tanks make
moves into Gaza which I think it's fair
to say an invasion but now we're seeing
full scale boots on the ground there's
some wide wild rumors going around we
got to be very careful of but people are
sharing it Lebanese reporters claiming
there's even US troops there I want to
be careful about that because we just
don't know for sure we don't want to Fan
the Flames but this is getting uh it's
getting hot to say the least and uh
Saudi Arabia is warning the US things
could get uh uh pretty intense and they
can get pretty intense pretty quickly so
uh we're going to talk a lot about that
that's basically the the the dominating
story right now there's Mass protests
happening at Grand Central Station in
New York many Jewish individuals who
live in New York are protesting what's
going on and this could spiral out of
control very quickly so uh welcome to
your Friday night fortunately for us we
have a sponsor that isn't afraid to get
behind shows with a great message and
that is cast brew.com why it's my
company so of course I sponsor myself
and I'm not worried about my sponsor
pulling out of my show no but to be fair
there are a lot of companies that don't
want to sponsor a show that's going to
be like here's a bunch of war and and
civilian casualties and so that's one of
the reasons we decided to make a product
where we sponsor ourselves but it's also
part of the bigger mission go to Cas
brew.com buy cbw coffee we have the
limited edition rise with Roberto Jr
it's limited it's just for Halloween and
we're making fun of our own dead mascot
which is kind of sad but we love
robberto Jr rest in peace and uh look
the bigger Mission with cast Brew is
we're building the coffee shop we're
working on the franchise agreements to
get that legal and sorted out so we can
create places for people to get together
and share their ideas create Community
locations where y'all can meet up and
hang out and that's part of the bigger
picture here so casper.com support the
show but also go to
timcast.net will say culture War soon to
be on tenet media I'm really excited for
this big shout out to everyone over at
tenet media uh Lauren Shen and everyone
I'm really excited this is going to be a
great project we'll have more on that
later but in the meantime smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends joining
us tonight to talk about Israel it's
Scott Horton hi Tim thank you for having
me who are you what do you do uh well
I'm the director of the libertarian
Institute I'm the editorial director of
antiwar.com I'm the host of the Scott
Horton Show I've got six ,000 interviews
almost
5,960 something going back to 2003 at
Scot
horton.com heavy metal band All That
Remains very failed musician
anti-communist and
counterrevolutionary Libby hey Phil hi
hi everybody I'm Libby Emmons I am the
editor with the post millennial on human
events filling in for Ian again glad to
be here Ian's just gone he messed me
he's like I'll be back at some he's in
Miami oh okay H he's on vacation you
know vacations happen it's nice to take
vacation you know what happen Ian a
vacation he started working out a
vacation yeah it's I don't know I'm
thinking maybe I'll look it up yeah must
be on Urban Dictionary started started
working out I think it's a and then now
he's doing tactical training with Luke
and using guns and I'm just like here
here goes he say he prayed to Jesus and
I'm like it's the it's the gym to Jesus
pipeline he's going to be in a
right-wing death squad the next thing
you know Ian know all right but Ian will
be back next week probably so uh we got
surge pressing the buttons do we you
introduce yourself already right I
didn't skip over you I did I'm good I'm
all good we got so wrapped up on Ian
it's okay I am here I'm waiting for Ian
to get back I'm excited to see him uh if
anyone's spring box reporter we got a
really big game this weekend we can beat
the All Blacks anyways all right here we
go Fox News has it Israel launches
second ground incursion into Gaza Hamas
Commander killed in air strike uh a
bunch of different reports this is all
ma major breaking news us won't draw red
lines for Israel in war with Hamas etc
etc we've got this story from the Daily
Mail quote Hamas will feel our wrath
tonight warns Israel as it unleashes
unprecedented air strikes on Gaza IDF
steps up ground operations and tells
Palestinians to flee South now as
Invasion Looms with phone lines and
internet cut across the city you were
mentioning just a moment ago there
there's a Scott that one of the one of
the uh I guess rumors or thoughts or
whatever is that Israel may try to split
the Gaza Strip in half between two
cities tell us what's going on well I
don't really know I have a Israeli
friend that sent me a message earlier
today that said The Invasion has begun
and I don't know the extent of it he
actually had also sent me uh a document
that was um a few years old that was a
military study an Israeli military study
about how to invade and conquer the
strip and they had a few different ideas
about how to go about it and I guess one
of them that my friend who was a a
veteran also he's a veteran of the 2006
Lebanon war um or Hezbollah War um he uh
he I think thought that this would be
the most likely uh take that they would
invade kind of in the middle of Gaza and
divide uh Kan Unis from Gaza City and um
you know they have a hell of a fight uh
if if they're really going if the
doctrine truly is to eradicate Hamas as
they had previously said to completely
eradicate Hamas they have a real fight
on their hands because they have
thousands of guys and they have these
very deep tunnels and in
2014 they started to invade and Hamas
guys were popping up out of the ground
out of all over the place and they were
taking casualties they were getting up
close and and kind of um ruining the
Israelis Advantage uh by taking them out
up close and the israelies they pulled
back and instead just went to artillery
and air power so if they're going to
truly quote unquote clean out the Gaza
Strip of Hamas it's going to cost
incredible casualties on both sides I
just want to mention you know we hear it
from uh Neo Libs in the United States
all the time about gun control about if
you want to go up against the US you
need nukes and all that stuff and it's
like dude guys with guns are dangerous
it's it's you can't occupy street corner
with a drone you can just terrorize and
devastate but if you want control of
something guys with guns you know so
that that's yeah now simar HS uh the
incredibly important journalist Seymour
HS has been writing that he has uh
contacts in Israeli intelligence and in
the military and whatever who are saying
that America has delivered um these
massive bunker Buster bombs which
there's essentially dropped from very
high altitude and Achieve very high
speed and then they have uh a double
charge the cone fires some kind of
superheated charge into the ground to
dig a hole down 30 40 m and then the
main charge which is also a shape charge
that's shaped downward go so that you
this is how to kill a bunker without
having to use a nuke is to use these
massive bunker Buster bombs and then the
idea is they're going to try to use
these to destroy the Hamas tunnels but
of course Hamas has dug their tunnels
deep enough to try to be protected from
those so we don't know if that'll really
work for them or not they're going to
have to do like tunnel rat type tactics
like they did in Vietnam and one of the
things that that I wanted to that I was
mentioning to Scott earlier that we
didn't want to talk about without being
on air is this is going to be if they do
decide to go into you know really go in
Full full scale it's going to be like
fujia you know in Iraq and that was
bloody and a lot of people died a lot of
innocent people died so the idea that
this is going to be some kind of easy
fight that is absolutely not the case
I'm uh I'm hoping that it's a crazy
thing to Hope but I'm I well not really
but I'm hoping that the Ukraine stuff is
fizzling out and that the the but I I'm
not so I'm not so sure right there
there's talk that the US is losing
interest in this because the shifting
fight a shifting fight is better than
expanding into World War III but I got
this for boting feeling as we're
preparing the show reports that you has
led air strikes on Iranian backed
targets already that's another story
we're we'll pull up in a second and I'm
like if the US is deploying tens of
thousands of 19,000 Personnel into the
region already some are saying that
they've been deploying the largest it's
the largest NATO Fleet ever amassed I
don't know if that's true but I'm seeing
these you know these these these images
and like various individuals in politics
posting these things may or may not be
true but we saw the the the announcement
last night the US has deployed uh many
more troops into the region we're
getting more moving from other areas
into this area feels like World War II I
have I have uh information that there
are Delta units being moved into the
area either tomorrow or the day after
something so there are rumors on Twitter
right now that us Elite forces delta
forces are in the conflict already in in
Gaza I don't I I'm I'm hard pressed to
believe that well there was a picture
last week of that they put the
incompetence in the White House posted
on Instagram a picture of Biden shaking
hands with Delta Force operators and
congratulating them for all the great
work that they're doing
Palestine I believe so no those those
guys were security detail okay they took
it down quickly also but you could when
they re when they reposted it with their
faces blacked out you could still see
their tattoos yeah I mean the
operational security there is completely
ridiculous but look as far as World War
III I don't know about you know look
there's slippery slope arguments where
Russia ends up involved here that kind
kind of thing but look at just the risk
of regional War where we could have you
know this war very
quickly never mind how difficult it is
for the people of Gaza and and the
Israeli conscripts who are invading
right now by the way but for the region
this very quickly could escalate to a
war with Hezbollah and Southern Lebanon
with all different kinds it's already
Syria of militias in Syria and why are
we in Syria we're in Syria for Israel
right Donald Trump tried to get us out
of Syria three different times and his
military overrode him three different
times they lied to his face and they
just canceled his orders three times and
why because well because America got rid
of Saddam Hussein and empowered Iran and
so now since the regime change against
Assad failed and Iran and Hezbollah had
even more influence in Syria than ever
before then America had to stay to
occupy that allom base on the So-Cal to
block the so-called land bridge from
Iran to Beirut and so that's why our
guys are there and then when Israel goes
and does what they're doing in Gaza now
then our guys are at risk and I actually
have a friend whose son is deployed in
Syria right now who's at risk of getting
killed over this you know there's that
guy that ran for congress in help me out
in Washington state that almost won the
Republican K Joe Kent who his wife was
killed in Syria after Trump ordered our
guys out and the military said no and
just said that order they said they said
you got it Trump don't do it yeah the
the idea well they made him back down
actually on the order this has happened
three times in 2017 2018 and then in his
lame duck session in December of 2020 he
ordered he said I want our guys out and
they essentially dragged their feet and
then forced him to back down and change
his mind and and look this gets to the
very bottom line right who who listening
to this show right now wants a rock War
four right after George W bush uh George
W bush put Iran's best friends in power
in Baghdad who wants to go back to Iraq
who wants to do another war in
Syria supporting Israel is not in the
interests of the United States of
America it's not and general James
Mattis and General David Petraeus both
in candid moments admitted they said
something very close to our men pay a
price in terms of their security in the
Middle East every day because of Israel
and what they do in Palestine and you
talk about fua here's a great example of
that in March of 2004 shik Yasin who was
the founder of Hamas who Israel had
financed and helped for years to grow
Hamas he started moderating his position
and trying to get along so they
assassinated him CU they don't want a
partner for peace we're going to talk
more about that they murdered him
because he was mellowing out and that
was in March of ' 04 was just like a
week later was the giant riot in fuah
maybe was two weeks later was the giant
riot in fua where the Blackwater guards
were lynched and their bodies burnt and
hung from the cour uh hung on the bridge
and one of the corpses was dragged
through this street um with another guy
tied to the hood of a car with a big
picture of shik Yasin in the window and
was the Israeli assassination of the
founder of Hamas had had helped to touch
off that Riot that killed those
Blackwater guards that then led to Bush
and maybe this is what Mattis was
referring to this led to Bush ordering
James Mattis to go in there and clean
them out and what they did was like a
free fire zone if you're a civilian
leave the city if you don't leave the
city your life is forfeit right like
Vietnam and so they didn't do that in
the other battles in Iraq War II but
they did that in fuia and that big the
first big battle of fua in March of 04
is what really kicked off the Sunni
based Insurgency that killed 4,000 of
our guys in Iraq War II and it was
because Israel assassinated their own
former sock puppet when he was becoming
a public relations liability for them I
wanted to point out when it came to
Biden and the leaked photo uh Telegraph
reports that it was a hostage Rescue
Unit in Israel yeah that's what I had
thought is that I you guys heard
something different or I think it was
security detail if it's Delta they don't
like to talk about what they're actually
doing well that was the Scandal the
Scandal was they leaked the information
on accident they weren't supposed on
Instagram yeah and that's why they
deleted it Delta Delta is top tier
Special Operations forces when they get
killed they don't report their
casualties right this is these guys are
clandestine forces top tier guys right
above the the special forces and so but
Israel that I I think I don't know if
they're going to I don't know if they're
going to put him into Israel and I this
is this is only like here say stuff that
I that I've I've got but it's my
understanding that they're probably
going to be going into the bases in
because there's there's a base in the
desert in Iraq that they that they
forward operate from so they can get
into Syria and stuff so if I understand
correctly they're going to be in that
area I don't know that they won't put
them in in support uh roles with the for
the IDF uh I think that more than likely
if there's a support Force it'd be the
the two Marine Expeditionary units that
are in the area that are on uh carriers
um you know Delta doesn't have enough
guys where they'd be a big support role
they're usually the the cuz there's only
a few hundred of them there's maybe like
500 well the post said that they have
generals embedded with the Israeli
military helping advis that could be not
sure advising is sure like we can have
an argument like why are we involved but
actual Warriors actual Fighters down
there that that's disconcerning and I
would also be very uh concerned about
the kind of person that gleefully Smiles
with excitement at meeting Joe Biden
yeah seriously no but but for real I
mean look if you talk to the average
American they don't like Joe Biden no
not you you you'll find your average
Democrat who despises Donald Trump with
the most extreme Trump derangement
syndrome does not like Joe Biden but
they'll still vote for him and that I
get that's fine my point is they don't
meet Joe Biden and go yeah fist bumb
high five like it's so great to meet you
and I look at this photo these guys
shaking Biden's hand and I'm like I
worried about although you know I mean
boss they're military and he's the
president that's basically all going you
know his approval rating is down 11
points among Democrats right now but
this this is my point the idea that
there are people who are like I'm
excited to meet him he's the boss hurah
and it's just like dude Biden's an evil
evil guy like you should be like I am
you should be ashamed that he is the one
giving orders agree but I think perhaps
for a lot of these guys that are doing
the top tier stuff they don't think Joe
Biden's the boss they well I mean the D
those like just because the picture they
they were smiling like I don't think
that I think it's likely that they were
putting a face on because you don't spit
in the face of the president I would be
I would be magnanimous if I met the
president I would say that it was a I
would be kind and smile as well you know
my my bigger concern is the excitement
to meet him and get a photo up and do
all these things instead of being like
look I get he's the president I'll be
respectful there's a difference I I I'm
I'm fairly confident I can't say for
sure but I'm I'm fairly confident that
they were getting ribbed later on the
dudes were like really cuz there are
people that I know that are that are
like not in the military that also know
dudes that are like like that and
they're just like yeah those they they
weren't well look I want to go back to
what you're saying about like you know
how could any of them have faith in him
as their commander-in-chief remember in
2013 Barack Obama tried to take us to
war in Syria over the first fake sarin
attack and
essentially the American Military and
and any potential volunteers were like
no we're not following Barack Obama into
battle that's our commanderin-chief
forget it well look if Barack Obama was
JFK then Joe Biden's LBJ who has faith
in him like no one you're going to sign
your son up for the service when Joe
Biden's the one calling the shots I mean
if you're already on the Delta team I
guess you might not quit but who wants
to send their son to join the ser
right now let's go back in time let's uh
yeah so we have this period under Barack
Obama oh boy did I fall for that one in
2008 I had all my friends being like
he's going to end these wars man we we
all hate the wars we all hate what
George W Bush was doing and I was like
all right whatever I guess we'll vote
for the guy and then Barack Obama gets
in and like day three he's like I'm
gonna blow some Gibs up gotta blow them
up too many of them and then we like I
remember one of the first too many of
them that's Sheamus joke Sheamus shout
out James cogin got to blow them up too
many and uh when it's like day three of
his president in Pakistan yeah it was
like 23 women and children were killed
in a village in an air strike or
whatever and I was just like that was
the wedding right wasn't it a wedding
it's been a long time there were a lot
of weddings I don't think that
particular one was but that one sticked
with me Pakistan civilians killed and I
said whoa whoa whoa whoaa hold on hold
on hold on he's there now Obama was
supposed to say no and then oh boy did I
learn quick how old was I 2008 and I was
just like well that was fun I'm out I
that in that election I remember cuz I
was in New York doing like Indie art
projects and everyone was on board with
Obama and I remember telling them like
he promised that he was going to send
more troops to Afghanistan and they were
like no he didn't and I was like no he
totally said he was going to send more
guys to Afghanistan which I can't vote
for him because of that because he's you
know my goal is to vote antiwar and they
were like well he's not going to do that
and then of course he did that these
were also the same people who when he
put the Obamacare into place that had a
mandate and if you didn't sign up for
health insurance you would get taxed
extra they were like that's great and
then when they got taxed extra they were
like why me seriously it's partisanship
is the mind killer it's the worst and
you're right he out vly said he was
going to escalate the Afghan war
although and I write about this I got I
got a chapter two on this in Fool's aand
what he really said he wanted to send a
couple brigades which was mostly just
like a PR thing that he was saying
Afghanistan is the good War Iraq is the
bad War whatever then as soon as he got
into power they just absolutely rolled
him and it was the secret AR of Defense
the chairman of the joint Chief of Staff
generals Petraeus and mccristal in
Alliance with McCain and Graham in the
Senate and they spent nine months
pressuring him to escalate that war by
70,000 troops which eventually he did
and and Lindsey Graham promised him he
said give us a number this is after he
already sent 40 Graham said give us us
being him and McCain give us a number
that starts with a three and we'll leave
you alone meaning 30,000 something more
troops and Obama made the deal so here
was his calculation right I'm going to
I'm going to Triple A war that I know I
can't win I know that I'm going to get
thousands of American soldiers shot and
blown up and killed I know I'm going to
get tens or hundreds of thousands of
Afghans killed but it's going to keep
John McCain off my back we made a deal
and and that was what he did and so he
escalated the war and then he lost it
anyway Lindsey Graham is vile evil you
saw what he just said recently right
yeah with or without evidence it's time
to start bombing Iranian Targets in he
wants to go to war with Iran so bad and
it I know that there are still like
holdovers in the in the government that
still think it's a good idea I don't
think that there is anyone in America
that thinks it's a good idea no regular
people in America they think it's a good
idea to engage in a war with Iran right
look in 2007 Dick Cheney and George Bush
wanted to they they were escalating the
war they launched the the Iraq War Surge
and then they even dropped the lies
about the nuclear weapons program for a
minute to focus on the lies that they
claimed and people should check this
it's not true and I wrote it all up in
enough already they claimed that Iran
was responsible for every roadside bomb
that went off in Shiite parts of Iraq
that's just not true they were all being
made in Iraq by Iraqis but that was the
propaganda and that was supposed to be
the excuse for the war and then what
happened was the The Joint Chiefs
brought George W bush to the Pentagon
and I believe this is in January or
February of 2007 and they went to the
tank like the secure room in the
basement or whatever and they told W
bush we're not going to Iran like maybe
the Air Force and the Navy talk tough
with their air power but the Army and
the Marines who are already getting
chewed up in Iraq and Afghanistan and
the Special Operations forces they will
die by the thousands and thousands and
maybe tens of thousands in a war because
you have to send it to to take out the
anti-aircraft you have to to send in
Special Operations forces with laser
designators to take out the
anti-aircraft and you sure can't win a
war or get a real regime change from the
air all you could do is some kind of
crazy punitive strike anyway right and
as they put it you need guys with guns
they said that's right we do not have
strategic uh I forgot the word for it
what was it the Strategic Domin that's
not the term for it I'm sorry um I
believe it was I'm sorry anyway the
point was the Pentagon they want to be
able to um oh escalate dominance pardon
me this was the term I'm looking for we
we don't want to fight unless we have
escalation dominance meaning we control
every stage of the war so when we do
this they'll do that but don't worry
because then we'll do this and then
they'll do that and but we have that
covered and they said but in the case of
Iran we do not have escalation dominance
in the case of Iran if we attack Iran
they have tens of thousands of missiles
now luckily we don't have 100,000 troops
in Iraq and Afghanistan anymore but we
got tens of thousands in Kuwait we still
do have thousands in Iraq low thousands
in Iraq
and we have the fifth Fleet navy base at
Bahrain and we have centcom headquarters
at the AL ulid base in Cutter and our
allies the Saudis Bahrain UAE have
trillions of dollars worth of economic
targets all up and down the western side
of that Gulf and if we go to war with
Iran every bit of that is up for grabs
including our Navy and Air Base there a
geography lesson would wake a lot of
Americans up very quickly so you can
pull this up this is Google Maps figure
it out as soon as you look at the map
you go now I get it Iraq
Afghanistan two amazing uh coincidental
countries for the US a bunch of military
bases in and Kuwait where we have a
bunch of troops I wonder why that may be
and what do you think Iran is thinking
surrounded by US military assets this
has been the plan for a long time in
fact Jen yuger mentioned uh um Wesley
Clark was that his name yes who talked
about the Seven Nations the US was
wanted to to invade and and uh Iran's
one of them have we has the US gone
after all of them already or or which
ones have almost okay so all right so
it's a great anecdote people who aren't
familiar you ought to look this up it's
General Wesley Clark he was the guy that
did the Kosovo War for Bill Clinton he
was the Supreme Allied Commander of NATO
in 1999 uh almost got us all killed in a
in World War III there ask me about that
otee later but anyway U and this gets
right to the neocons and the Israel
Lobby in the United States um he went to
the Pentagon right after September 11th
and an officer saiden come here I want
to show you something and showed him
this piece of paper he said this is the
plan for a regime change in the new war
he said we're going to war with Iraq and
Wesley Clark said Iraq why would we go
to Iraq they don't have anything to do
with September 11th or Al Qaeda of
course and the guy said yeah no check it
out so the list was I hope I can get
this right the list was Iraq Lebanon by
which they meant not necessarily
everyone in Beirut but hez Bala in
Lebanon Syria Libya
Somalia and did I already say Sudan and
Iran ending with Iran well they got they
did Iraq War II they failed to do the
regime change in Syria they did Libya
they broke off the south from
Sudan um and you know there was a regime
change there although I don't know if
there was America's sock puppets really
that took over or not they certainly
broke the country in half and so the
only one left um is uh well and and hez
Bala still stands yeah and then is Iran
and so look this gets to all of a rock
word too let's talk about the clean
break have you ever read the paper a
clean break have you ever heard of that
okay so um David wormser is an important
Neo conservative apparat he was foreign
policy adviser to Dick Cheney in the W
bush uh first W bush term and in 1996
when Benjamin Netanyahu was brand new
the first the first time he was the
Prime Minister of Israel he came in in
'96 and David wormser Douglas FEI and
Richard Pearl wrote this study these are
American neoconservatives it's called a
clean break a new strategy for securing
the realm and they wrote it for
Netanyahu and what it says is this it
says
Iran Syria and
Hezbollah are the threat to Israel
particularly Hezbollah in southern
Lebanon backed by Iran and Syria and
what we want to do is we want to break
that
chain and then get this they said to
break that chain what we want to do is
we want to get rid of Saddam Hussein in
Iraq huh Saddam Hussein is the Sunni the
minority Sunni dictator sitting on a
super majority Shiite
population and Iran and hezb of course
are these fundamentalist Shiite regimes
so why does it make sense to these
neocons to get rid of Saddam Hussein
well it was this ridiculous Rube
Goldberg scheme that they had come up
with if we get rid of Saddam Hussein
who's rub Goldberg oh rub Goldberg is
the guy that makes the ridiculous like
the trap machine like 100 little gears
turn to make yeah peew Herman's
breakfast machine that's exactly right
PE Herman's breakfast that's that's
there probably a lot of young people
some what yeah y'all y'all get the
peewee's Big Adventure Off The Pirate
Bay tonight it's it's a classic it's a
great I think it's on probably on
Netflix must be but look so so here was
the scheme okay The rubbe Goldberg
scheme was if we get rid of Saddam
Hussein then we will get the cousin of
the King of Jordan to take over Iraq and
because he's a hashemite with the blood
of the prophet in his veins all the
Shiites will just bend over and kiss his
bottom and do whatever he says which
this is completely crazy the Shiites
don't rever the hashemites at all the
hashimites are sunnis and even though
the Shiites rever the bloodline of the
Prophet it's not like they're priests
and even priests and Cardinals and
Bishops don't have like political
control over their people directly so in
other words they were living in this
fantasy world that the Shiites of Iraq
would become compliant under the new
pro-american installed and pro-israeli
installed regime and then because Shiite
Islam is born in Iraq and then spread
into Iran they would get the Shiite
clergy in Naj to order Hezbollah to stop
being friends with Iran and start being
friends with Israel and and Iraq under
these compliant Shiites would then give
the full advantage to America Jordan
Turkey and Israel our friends in the
region against Iran well Tim this is the
dumbest damn thing this makes no sense
at all and and people can read it's
called a clean break by wormser the
followup is called coping with crumbling
States and if you really want to know
they wrote a book about it called
tyranny's Ally and then what really
happened in Iraq War II what happened in
Iraq War II was Bush overthrew the
minority Sunni dictator and he put the
super majority Shiite population in
charge and their political factions who
happened to be guys who'd been living in
Iran for 30 years since Jimmy Carter had
hired Saddam Hussein to invade Iran back
after the Revolution and so they were
the ones who came and inherited the
whole thing so when we think about Iraq
War II of the George W bush years that
whole fiveyear Civil War that was going
on that was Bush fighting for Iran's
side in the war against his own friends
because that was what the
neoconservatives thought would be good
for Israel I saw this post on Twitter
they were talking about how Biden's
approval collapsed after the Afghan
withdrawal and instead of making the
point that Joe Biden botched the
withdrawal and uh Ian goes off calling
it a surrender I mean it seems on
purpose they said it was a bad play by
Trump and Biden shouldn't have followed
through instead of it was the right play
by Trump and Biden intentionally in my
op op flub the whole thing but but this
is the point this is what we the reason
why I'll say intentionally now in my
opinion is that at the time we were
asking did Biden screw this up on
purpose to sour the idea of withdrawal
in the minds of the American public the
reality was you could withdraw from
Afghanistan without causing what what
what Biden caused but now what I'm
seeing is journalists say Trump's plan
was bad and Biden is getting blamed for
it no Biden's plan plan was Trump put
the plan in place way earlier in the
spring he made that promise and there
were plenty of opportunities to get
started on that withdrawal and what
happened was no I I hear what you're
saying the Biden Administration refused
to get started on the withdrawal and so
they had to do it the last minute it's
not just that it's they they abandoned
bam in the middle of the night without
telling the aghan security forces they
left all I think they turned it over to
the to the Ana but the Ana couldn't hold
it we lost3 in the midle of the night
the US forces pulled out without without
notice and regular afghanis looted the
the the buildings and uh uh uh there
were helicopter Pilots I think this is
like New York Times reporting that
instantly lost Logistics and didn't know
what's going on landed the helicopters
and ran away yeah because they were like
there's no one anymore no I'm not talk
there was it was just it was an insane
insane move and I think what they wanted
yes Joe Biden gets the negativity from
it but they don't think Joe I do not see
Joe Biden being the candidate in 2024 it
makes literally no sense he's there
their their sacrificial lamb their
scapegoat now what they're going to do
and they're starting to do it is saying
you see what happens when we withdraw
it's chaos American side we can't we
have to stay and keep the troops
overseas goad everything that was bad
about the the uh the withdraw from
Afghanistan was all tactics it was not
none of it was policy
like it was insane how they left all of
the all of the weapons but now what we
have is the Taliban saying if you give
me safe passage we'll destroy Israel for
you well they're not getting anywhere
near Israel check the map again put the
map up I'm just saying that's that's
that that is the goal of the Taliban is
now here thing so look you make a great
point about the narrative here about oh
yeah see what happens when you ever
leave anywhere something bad happens
right you're you're right I don't
believe that that was the reason that
they did what they did though and I can
explain why here's what they did okay
Trump as she said absolutely correctly
Libby said Trump's deal was we leave by
May 1st we're out by May the 1st okay
that's the start of the fighting season
right everything's frozen over until the
summertime essentially comes that's the
start of the fighting season we were
supposed to be gone by then Biden came
in and said well I don't want to live up
to Trump's deal I want it to be my
Afghan withdrawal not Trump's Afghan
withraw and I don't want people to be
able to say that I did what Trump said I
had to do and this and that so what did
he do he kicked the can down the road
for 4 months to September which remember
they said we're going to do it September
11th like what do they do just
in Afghanistan they were like H you kind
of promised but here's a deal that you
guys need to understand about the war
okay the war was lost they had to leave
okay Bush and Obama lost that war before
Trump ever got there the Taliban were
ascendant they controlled 60% of the
country in the daytime they controlled
80 or more percent of it at night part
of it was they didn't know what a wind
looks like they didn't know what the
wind would look like the policy was
wrong look let's just stick with the
withdrawal here for a second
if Biden was going to tell the truth to
the American people about that war he
would have had to tell them listen we
lost the government that we built has no
popular support it cannot stand the
military that we built has no popular
support it cannot stand we failed we're
leaving but he couldn't do that right he
had to say what did he say he said we
won the war it was great we built a
great government in Cabell which will
surely last for years and we built this
great magnificent Afghan National Army
300,000 men strong and it's sure to last
for years too that's why we can leave
not because we blew it but because we
did it everybody and so now we can go
well by sticking to that lie that meant
they had to leave all those weapons in
the hands of the Afghan National Army
that couldn't hold on to them and ended
up turning them all over to the Taliban
and because they had to pretend that
they had created a government worth its
salt in Cobble they couldn't abandon it
and leave the city early or they would
have been accused of undermining the
government and being the reason that it
fell so they had to stick with their lie
that everything is fine meanwhile the
Taliban are walking right into Cabell
because it's four months behind schedule
that they're leaving and you know and
you know what else comes from this with
the Taliban getting access to a lot of
these weapons certainly they can't
maintain a lot of it so a lot of it just
instantly Falls yeah but with a lot of
the guns and the uh uh the the the
materials that are available to just
Ground Forces it allows the us to have a
recurring problem and reason to be in
the Middle East it's also they also um
hard to get back to Afghanistan I me
it's not even necessar about Afghanistan
it's the reporting that or the rumors at
least that weapons left behind by the US
are being used by Hamas and other and
other uh reporting from The Wall Street
Journal they were reporting about that
in in June that that was likely to be
happening and there's also reports that
that the technology has been reverse
engineered and like that they're able to
build you know we saw that video of them
trying to fly a helicopter and they're
like going in circles or whatever when
ites they can make AK-47 yeah when it
comes to the Small Arms there like
there's there's they're building AK-47s
and they're building at least Small Arms
in the mountains of Afghanistan between
uh Pakistan and Afghanistan there's
there's a a whole arms market up there
where you can go and buy copies of of
fully vitton handbags except AK
let me tell you a story though here's
how my first book that was this book
about all of the terror Wars became a
different book Fool's Aaron about
Afghanistan it's CU I got stuck in
Afghanistan because it's such a huge
story it's 20 years long and but the
whole thing takes place east of Persia
and then and so I knew it was people are
going to be mad at me that it takes too
long before we get to Iraq War II so I
ended up you know what fine I'll just do
a whole book about Afghanistan and I'll
get back to the to the rest of the
Middle East later because the rest of
the whole story of the Bush and Obama
years takes place in Mesopotamia and the
Levant what's going on in Afghanistan is
I hate to say it but almost Irrelevant
in a sense it's separate from the rest
of the story whereas the war in Iraq
immediately bleeds to Libya to Syria and
the rest of the story comes from Bush
Jr's invasion of Iraq War II and 03 do
you think religion uh plays a role in
high level uh military
uh I'm try to be careful here uh
obviously religion plays a role to
varing degrees but do you think that
actual like uh revelatory religious
fanaticism is a component in the Air
Force more than other places but yes I
do I think in the Air Force yes you know
there's a guy named Mikey Weinstein who
sued about this over and over and over
again about um you know religious
freedom inside the services and it's
particularly the Air Force has been
taken over at least this is my dad is 10
years old here but uh from what I heard
before had real Holy Rollers who believe
that yeah nuclear war will help Force
Jesus to come back and all this kind of
stuff there are people who really
believe that with power and influence in
this country that that and it's it's
it's tough because I think aam's Razer
is always there's money to be made for
the military industrial complex there's
power to be had there's grudges there's
generational conflict but we are I bring
this up because there are uh people
pushing this rumor and and you know I
think Jen kind of took it the wrong way
when I said
that uh there's videos of people
claiming you know Israel is the Blessed
Holy Land members of Congress saying
this and many people who believe that
there has to be this war for there to be
the Messianic era or whatever I'm not
talking about any of these anti-semitic
conspiracy theories about world control
dominance I'm talking about people who
generally just believe the Bible sure
and the Bible says that there will be
this Great War there's been uh people
have been T there's uh uh forward I
think it was forward.com wrote about the
red heer that was born I'm not saying I
believe any of that is true I'm
wondering to what degree does a lot of
people are very deeply religious I'm
wondering to what degree that influences
their actions I I think it
has I guess I would say in the in the
councils of the highest levels of the
Pentagon and the White House I don't
think that they have that much influence
but in the nation in the country overall
they do and in the Republican party and
in the Congress they absolutely do I
mean look after September 11th Coleen
Powell told George Bush just like James
Baker told his father your approval
rating is through the roof we have to do
a Palestinian State now now is the time
this is one of the main causes of
terrorism against our country is the
Israelis oppression of the Palestinians
and Bush was convinced and they started
to do it wow and then what happened was
Tom DeLay the House Majority Whip from
Texas came to W bush and said you want
to be a one-term president like your
father because I'll turn every Born
Again Evangelical Christian in this
country against you and you will be
toast why do you think the uh why do you
think the Palestinians have for so long
even going back to the founding of
Israel rejected a two-state solution
even the one Bill Clinton proposed I
think in '92 that was really generous
and and pretty strong and given them a
lot we're skipping around a lot here I'm
just asking your opinion on that okay I
mean if you want to go back to the
beginning of it it was because this what
11% of the population were claiming to
own half the land more than half the
land and everyone else was going to have
to get the hell out of the way and
violently there have been so many
violently massing them and cleansing
them from their homes and so they said
no but then what happened I mean first
of all well there's a lot of first of
alls here but what happened was Israel
made a secret deal with the King of
Jordan that he would keep the west bank
and then at the end of the war they had
Egypt keep the Gaza Strip just so that
the Palestinians could not have their
state so quite contrary to this myth
that Israel has done nothing but tried
to give the Palestinians Independence
all this time I'm talking about the
American proposals there's been a lot of
American proposals well that was in ' 92
but you asked about 48 right I'm saying
why why have they rejected it all along
like you're saying it's a different
reason each time well I mean to skip
from 48 to '92 is tough and there's
obviously a lot issue here if you want
to do let me do the the narrative in the
broad stroke thing okay so so picture
your map of of Israel and Palestine that
you have in your head right now in the
19 1948 War I mean forget morality and
normative just descriptive okay Israel
won the war and they cleansed
750,000 Palestinians out of what we now
call Israel proper within the 67 borders
okay and they pushed them into other
nations across the Middle East and they
pushed them into the Gaza Strip and the
West
Bank uh and they took as far as West
Jerusalem okay now regardless of you
know who you sympathize with or whatever
just factually speaking that was
sustainable what they created was
sustainable in the sense that they
created an
8020 super duper majority Jewish
democracy had 80% Jews 20% Palestinian
Muslims and Christians inside Israel
we're talking about now not the occupied
territories and this is after The Six
Day War this is after the um wasn't that
67 I'm talking before 67 Oh I thought
you were talking about' 67 okay yeah no
so' 67's next right okay so before ' 67
they had created essentially this 8020
super duper majority Jewish democracy
then in the 67 War which was started by
Israel they claimed it was preemptive
regardless Israel won the war the
Palestinians of course had nothing to do
with it they were just stuck in the
middle um but Israel beat Jordan and
Egypt and Syria in that war and they
took the Gaza Strip and the West Bank
and you could say guys that look they
really de facto annexed all of Gaza and
the West Bank
then EGP was pissed for sure but they
kept all the people so unlike in 1948
where they drove all the people off
their land and created this 8020 super
duper majority Jewish State they let
everyone stay in their homes well they
couldn't force them all out they
actually did Force 235,000 people out of
their homes more out of their homes but
they still overall they kept the people
of the West Bank so they're essentially
kidnapped now right so they are they're
they were conquered were they kidnapped
or they were let to stay where they
lived well it's sort of the same thing
in a sense I mean it's a turn of phrase
here that I'm using but what I'm what
I'm trying to tell you is that Palestine
the the Palestinian people have had
nothing like Independence this whole
time they've been under the occupation
of Israel first the under Jordan and
Egypt and then under Israel since
67 okay so when like Ben Shapiro for
example or my friend here last night on
Twitter says well what would we do if
the Mexicans were attacking us across
our international border here
cels well even then we' do nothing
because we are being
attacked by Cartel and we do nothing so
we let for we open we kiss them on the
cheeks what we give them Xboxes and
Tents we let them populate Central Park
all right let's do the southern Border
in a minute um but so un unlike in the
Ben Shapiro analogy which everybody's
heard a million times there is no
international border here see when you
most people I'm not saying in this room
but I just mean in America generally
speaking if you say the Israelis and the
Palestinians well it sounds like the
Palestinians already have a country cuz
everybody has a country and you just
called them Palestinians so they must be
from the country called Palestine right
at said no you got a bug right behind
you on your chair there buddy oh yeah
those little stink bugs they do their
thing guy he is actually cute friendly
little guy he was over here for a while
so what happened was
um the uh blasted him he's alive though
I just blew him off with the so so since
67 they've been under occup patient now
David benu and the first Prime Minister
said this is crazy we shouldn't do this
we should let them go right now we don't
want to essentially in a way again
accept my turn of phrase import by
expanding their territory they're in a
sense importing this massive population
of Palestinian Muslims and Christians
that they don't want and so David benan
Jordan doesn't want them Egypt doesn't
want them no one wants them well and
that's partially because if the Israeli
Jews are are able to cleanse all of
historic Palestine of all their Muslim
population then they lose all their
claim to their holy sites it's their
land that they want to keep they were
the ones who were there first they're
the ones being cleansed from their land
by the Israelis well first means they
were living there all along but and for
for Generations back into Antiquity when
a bunch of Russians and lithuanians and
Germans and New Yorkers showed up and
said the land belonged to them Antiquity
and yeah into yeah ancient times in fact
here I'm glad this has come up cuz I got
a great quote for you here I've been
talking about this lately but I had
forgotten what the actual Source was but
you're saying but the actual source is
David benu and himself you're saying
that who said uh Muslims always always
had this had been there that's right
because here's why because when the
Muslims came and took over that land
they did not cleanse the land of the
people who lived there all and they did
not invade it with a giant occupying
Force to replace them all they did was
take them over and tax them and then the
deal was if you convert to Islam you get
a uh tax cut basically you pay less and
so the local uh people all converted to
Islam and this and essentially by Yeah
by coersion right and so but wait but so
these are the same people who are the
descendants of the ancient Hebrews and
the source for this is David benu and
himself okay this is from Sheldon
Richmond's book which we published at
The Institute and Sheldon my good friend
was raised Jewish and Zionist until he
learned all of this stuff and he wrote
this great book coming to Palestine
about it and and on page 11 and 12 here
he quotes David benan and his partner
yito benv who is Israel's second
president and and who was also a
professional historian and they wrote a
book in 198 18 called arrests Israel in
the past and in the present and in there
I won't read you the whole quote but in
there they describe in detail benan says
the ancient Hebrews never left you can't
take a farmer from his soil they were
there the whole time and so the what was
happening was the descendants of the
ancient Hebrews in who had stayed in
Palestine were being replaced by the
descendants of the ancient Hebrews who'd
gone off to Europe and then their
descendants came home as there's no
statute of limitations and 3,000 years
later you can come and say this is my
land you can't live here when but if the
if the argument is one people conquered
another people then all you're arguing
now is other people are conquering other
people right like well that's right but
but look I'm not okay with any of it but
I understand it happened and I you know
I wonder what the solutions would be we
trying to minimize casualties look I
mean all we're trying to do here is
describe the reality of the situation
Tim most of the time again if you listen
to Ben Shapiro which many people people
do you would think there already was
some kind of two-state solution and now
the nation state of Palestine has sent
its terrorist forces to attack and
invade Israel when that's not what
happened what happened was essentially
Indians broke out of their reservation
and attack the people in town and that's
not a fight between sovereigns that's a
fight essentially between refugees in a
prison camp versus the nation state that
conquered them and when you at least it
was it's against the population because
they did go after innocent people that's
right of course they did and and let's
talk about that in just a second but
just overall just the situation of who's
attacking who and and the relative power
like if America went to war with Mexico
that wouldn't be a fair fight but at
least they have a national government
and a national Army different be a fight
that's different than if we just start
carpet bombing the Navajo reservation
out in Arizona I mean imagine imagine
some some Indians in the reservation out
west going to town and Massacre a
thousand anglos do we carpet bomb the
reservation or we find the people who
are responsible and their commanders
whoo if the Navajo massacred a thousand
Americans off the reservation yeah it'd
be federally
occupied Wipe Out the reservation no no
we would not no we would not no we would
no we would find the individuals
responsible and the men who sent them
and we would hold them to
account they would be they would be
prosecuted in Criminal Court we killed a
million people in Iraq September 11 we
massacred everybody at Waco and Ruby
Ridge for far less not an ement of it
and look they killed a hell of a lot of
Indians at Wounded Knee too and and
second Wounded Knee however okay let me
rephrase let me rephrase would you
support would you support carpet bombing
and Indian Reservation over an atrocity
when you know good and Damned well that
the FBI and the Marshall service can
handle this no you're going to send in
the military and and you know you're
going to kill innocent people if you're
saying that if you're saying that the
Navajo Nation which struggles to have
electricity and Refrigeration just to
afford like the people of Gaza no like
the people of the Navajo Nation the
Navajo hopei reservation right like
there's solar panel structures to keep
refrigerators going to make sure that
they have insulin the insulin stays cold
if you're saying that these people if
they if like there was a if there was a
mili to the point where um they had a
militia and they decided to murder a
thousand Americans I think that would
first of all that would be really
shocking and I would think very long and
hard about the the structure of the um
you know well that's a great point you
would wonder what they were so upet
about the department of the Interior no
I wouldn't worry what they were upset
about but I I would well maybe Hillary
Clinton sold their uranium to the
Russians and they all got cancer and
they're actually upset and got something
to fight about let me okay let me let me
literally answer the question instead of
just going back and forth um if the
Navajo Nation mounted a raid that killed
1,000 Americans it's not it's not some
arbitrary question of carpet bombing
them it's a question of military
capabilities what we expect in terms of
future actions against us and what
amounts to Justice I would be quite
concerned with a carpet bomb on the
navoo re reservation because they don't
have support from Iran or they don't
have access to Rockets they're not
produced we're not being bombed by them
consistently
Rockets aren't launching out of various
areas we don't need to do that yes the
marshals and US forces could go in there
but even if they were armed with rockets
I mean look we call them Rockets because
you don't dare call them missiles
because they're not real missiles and
they didn't get shipped from Iran they
made them out of water pipes right there
these are you know uh barely amount to
katucha Rockets the fact look the reason
it's so important that we talk about the
difference between you know whether
we're talking about a Sovereign Nation
or an Indian reserv
what you're supposed to take from that
is everybody in this country knows that
the great white father back East Joe
Biden and his armed forces have one
billion times the strength and the power
of any Indians on any reservation and
that if they did break out and commit
some terrible atrocity that Uncle Sam
ought to be able to negotiate a peaceful
solution from here and again the
individuals responsible would be
prosecuted in court it wouldn't be a war
they would go to they would go to court
and then they'd be hanged Michael rhyo
and was he was he given his day in court
who's that the guy who shot Aaron dson
in Portland I don't know I mean the
branch of idian didn't get their day in
court either but they should have should
have I do not expect the US government
to be honest and bear Integrity when
dealing with these things did did did
did did people of Iraq get a fair trial
after 911 the US just decided to lie to
wage war overseas which resulted in
Untold deaths and we're still pissed off
about it uh it was it was an insane move
that we went to Afghanistan in Iraq over
911 911 was an atrocity uh uh that this
country and for this country everybody
knows that and 3,000 people lost their
lives the stories that come out of 911
are uh they're stories of great heroism
which Inspire but the whole day was just
so horrifying and the reaction was just
Untold more dead with lies the US did
not have a fair day in court I I I fully
expect evil actions uh should should
something like that occur I wish it was
but dude you're talking about a bunch of
Egyptians and Saudi Nationals who hijack
planes working for a foreign terrorist
group in my analogy in two countries
wait no we're talking about Indians on
the reservation because we're talking
about Israel and the Palestinians that's
not the same as al- Qaeda attacking us
on an international Jihad we're talking
about look in the point about bringing
up the Navajo is not to to impune the
Navajo it's to point out that they are
already lit they're already beaten they
live in a concentration camp under the
total control of the United States
government so if so if something hold on
like well no I look it's not a Perfect
Analogy but I'm just saying the relative
power versus the Indians on the res
versus the US federal government means
if something very terrible happens the
onus should be on the American national
authorities to resolve it peacefully
from there not to call in the Army to
wipe out a bunch of innocent men women
and children and look at the history of
Israel and Palestine here where they've
had problems with terrorism from the
leftists from the nationalists from the
islamists the whole time and how do they
handle it they win and they get them one
at a time it's only since Netanyahu that
they do these massive bombing campaigns
you can go in again we're talking about
a reservation you can go in pick these
guys off one at a time so you think the
response to from the Hamas attack would
be for Israel to do like strategic
incursion with forces to remove Hamas
yes they should listen to said they
should I don't care about that listen
what you just said was that America got
all emotional and did a bunch of stupid
wrong things after September 11th Israel
ought to listen to you and they ought to
not do that they ought to be smart and
look I wrote an article a couple of
weeks ago and and we do need to get into
why Netanyahu likes so much and
supported them in Palestine uh because
that's a huge part of this okay because
we get we keep getting distracted off
our points and probably that's mostly my
fault but um uh and hell now I forgot
what I was going to say about that
talking about the you were you were
leading to the comment uh the the link
you sent which is something that I was
the reaction reaction the reaction okay
stuff so look okay yes you guys are
familiar with solinsky the leftist
radical Community organizer guy right
okay page 74 of Rules for Radicals says
that in all asymmetric political action
the action is in the reaction of the
opposition yeah right so like Bin Laden
has a group of 400 Bandits he's trying
to take on the superpower how do you do
it you get the superpower to kill itself
right right you give them an opportunity
to go wild and do something
self-destructive okay in this case Hamas
was trying and probably there are people
who are siding with the Palestinians who
might not want to hear this part of it
the reason that Hamas committed the
atrocity that they committed October 7th
yes on October the 7th which by the way
an extended family member of mine was
abducted and murdered by Hamas in that
atrocity condolences okay and and by the
way my wife almost would have died on
September 11th except she was homesick
at her parents house but she had an
office in the tower and would have been
killed on September 11th okay so I don't
have any love or sympathy for these AR
armed islamist murderers that's exactly
what they are okay but they're not just
devils and they're not just angry
children and Muhammad didn't come from
hell to give them instructions to do a
Bad Thing these are human men and
they're fighting about politics so why
they why' they do it so why they did it
was to provoke Netanyahu into doing
exactly what he's doing now carpet
bombing the Gaza Strip slaughtering God
Palestinian civilians by the thousands
knew that this would result in a Massac
of their own people that's
exactly right wait wait wait let me
finish real quick one point for your
question of course Hamas knew
motivations aside there there's no other
reaction not just they knew not just
that not just they knew this is what
they wanted to happen Okay absolutely
because with the reaction then comes all
the counter reaction actions right so
what how we start the show at the top of
the show today America hits Iranian SES
in Syria because they had sent drones
after our guys in Syria because of what
Israel is doing in Gaza right it at the
Lebanese border with Hezbollah you got
so far just pot shots going off back and
forth but that could quickly escalate
wait wait now every Shiite militia in
Iraq has to take a stand the Ayatollah
in tyan gets to get up there and beat
his chest now every Sunni King in Arabia
all of the American sock puppets
Muhammad bin uh Solon and and Muhammad
bin zad in in Saudi and in UAE they all
have to take a stand are they going to
be silent uh because they're good little
sock puppets of the Empire or are they
going to agree with 100% of the public
opinion of the people in their countries
this could destabilize the whole region
it's already remember when I was here a
year and a half ago we talked about the
Abraham Accords Y and what was the
purpose of the Abraham Accords this was
the Netanyahu doctrine that said we can
with enough American tax
money we can make peace well not peace
but we can finally permanently normalize
relations with Bahrain UA not Bahrain
with uh it was UA bahin UA Saudi Sudan
and Morocco that's right and we can do
this without without making peace with
the Palestinians that's right and so
made the Palestinians pissed off and so
they took a couple of years to plan this
attack that's right and then and then
look what happened they they got the
reaction that they wanted and now that
all of the Abraham Accords are in
Jeopardy right and look and this is
let's let's get real honest about here
about this even if you absolutely love
Israel and I don't know any reason why
not to it's a land full of civilians I
love them just as much as everybody else
okay you wouldn't wor you wouldn't you
would not wish
Netanyahu on the people of Israel and he
has been the longest serving prime
minister in Israeli history longer than
uh than David benan okay they call him
King
BBE and so like think if September 11th
had happened in Bill Clinton's thirdd
term his approval rating would have gone
down right Bush got was off the hook
because he'd only been on the job for
eight measly months before that attack
happened on his watch right this is
happening in netanyahu's fifth term okay
this is his policy finally come to
fruition it was called the Netanyahu
Doctrine and the Netanyahu Doctrine
said unlike yso Rabin who one of his
fans assassinated in
1995 unlike ysac Rabin who said we want
to demonize Iran so that we can
negotiate and make peace with the Arabs
including the Palestinians the Netanyahu
Doctrine said no we'll make peace with
the demonize Iran make peace with the
Arabs but not with the Palestinians and
you can hear him just three weeks ago in
his United Nations address he explains
exactly the thinking behind this he says
they always said that we could never um
uh normalize relations with the rest of
the nations of the region uh and and uh
therefore then have peace with the
Palestinians unless we make peace with
the Palestinians first and give up
Palestinian State first and only then
will we be able to get along but we
showed them and we're so smart and we
made these deals without um giving up a
Palestinian State and he said but we
will have peace and what he's
essentially saying between the lines is
we're going to have the piece of total
Victory here the Palestinians will get
nothing and they'll learn to like it
they'll never have Independence and
they'll never have freedom I got some
trivia for you uh and then this happened
two weeks after he said that for one
week after he said that at the UN look
at me I got away with it
everybody called for I got I got I got
some trivia for you okay what is what
does this mean that's peace this is
Victory right but the the origin of this
Sans sign is the same thing F you the
it's making the V for victory and so
what happens is after the battle when
they hold up the two fingers we call it
peace why because you killed all your
enemies yeah the Peace of desolation the
peace has been achieved we one and so
when people are like peace out the
origin of that is after your enemy was
killed you held up the V for victory I
always thought that this was this was Fu
because the archers would hold up two
fingers because when they when they got
caught they would cut off one of the
fingers so they couldn't pull the where
this comes from this which which people
now say peace but the peace is it's
peace after you wi so this brings us
back to the clean break okay because
what was the purpose of of getting rid
of Saddam so that we can weaken hez Bala
it was so that we don't have to abide by
the Oslo agreement and negotiate an
independent Palestinian state but if we
screw over the Palestinians while we
still have Hezbollah on our northern
border then that's an extra pressure and
so the whole point of the clean break
strategy was we need to get America to
go to war in Iraq for us so that we
don't have to give Justice to the
Palestinians what do you I wanted to ask
uh when you mentioned Hamas knew this
was going to happen do you think they
knew I I mean you're you're outlining
this this this story of Domino's falling
over which could lead to World War II
and the first thing I thought was if you
are Hamas in Gaza you're thinking World
War III is is is our only path to any
kind of
change well look again I think World War
II is a little hyperbolic I I don't
foresee Russia getting involved although
it could happen something like that
we're already in a massive proxy war
against Russia right now as we all know
which is uh horrifying and terrifying um
but they're not that close with the
Ayatollah you know Russia and Iran they
have their own tensions going back and
they've been getting along okay and and
Iran has been sending drones for the
Russian war effort and that kind of
thing but they don't have like a treaty
of Alliance where Russia would go to war
for Iran and quite frankly I
think I think worst case scenario here
the war spreads to Lebanon and possibly
Iraq but I really think that the
Americans and and the ayatolla guys too
have got to be cautioning him and I
think the American Military has got to
be telling Joe Biden how badly they do
not want to fight Ira Iran you put that
map up earlier there a countryes what
three four times the size of Afghanistan
Afghanistan is the size of Texas okay
people don't understand this too um
that's why I say a geography lesson and
this is mountains too topography lesson
counts too this isn't flat desert like
Iraq you cannot win here man mountains
massive with massive air defense the US
military Doctrine is is defined by its
air superiority I I I really now I don't
know how much I believe that there is a
is a war with Iran coming like whether
cooler heads will prevail or not but I
strongly believe that if it does happen
the US will justify using tactical
nuclear weapons because they'll they'll
want to take out the oil reserves
they'll want to take because that's what
Lindsey Graham's after
or they'll use moabs as big as they
possibly can if they don't want to get
on they don't want what do you make of
Iran having um trained Hamas
Fighters well look I mean they have a a
real interest in disrupting the
situation in Israel and Palestine you
really want I mean Iran was training
Hamas Fighters before they were even
Hamas like back in the late 80s when
Hamas was essentially forming in yeah in
Lebanon with Hezbollah so well no
that's different yeah Hamas Hamas is
yeah and they're they're part of the
Muslim Brotherhood and I want to
recommend to you and and to everyone
listening a great book by Robert dfus
called Devil's game how the United
States helped unleash fundamentalist
Islam so it's the US's fault that the
the extr yes because America inherited
all of the European and the Japanese
World Empires after World War II America
is the dominant force in the Middle East
even though we're the middle part of
North created the people that hate us
now is that I'm just trying to
understand what you're saying not not
created in the like oversimplified sense
but yes the enemy in the Cold War was
first the commies and second the
nationalists and who's opposed to both
the commies and the nationalists the
islamists and so America and Britain and
Saudi Arabia spent billions spreading
fundamentalist Islam throughout the
region and not just the wahabism of
Saudi but the Muslim Brotherhood
essentially was meant to disrupt all
secular politics in the region for
generations and did so that was the
purpose of it and that was why America
backed the Muslim Brotherhood that was a
huge part of the reason of course that
America and Saudi worked together to
send a bunch of guys Proto alqaeda guys
to fight the Soviets in Afghanistan in
the 1980s which is where muad those
that's right well because see there was
the Afghan mujahadin but then there was
the Arab Afghan Army and these were
mercenaries again look at the map all of
these guys are Arabs then you have
Persia and then you have the Afghans who
are hazaras and tajiks and USCS and
pashun right they're not Arabs at all so
they sent they got all these Arabs to
come and sent them to fight in
Afghanistan including the guys who were
the leaders of what became Islamic Jihad
and al- Qaeda that ended up turning
against the United States so and in fact
most people don't know this but
throughout the 1990s when Al Qaeda was
already attacking the United States Bill
Clinton kept supporting them anyway he
supported them in Bosnia and in Kosovo
and in cnia and you might Remember When
Vladimir Putin declared war on Ukraine
two and a half or a year and a half ago
in his declaration of war he said and
it's I like the way he did this too
because he knew it was going to sound
like conspiracy stuff so he phrased it
like this he goes come on let's be
adults about this we know what you and
Britain were doing in
Chia right that was true America was
supporting B ladite head chopper suicide
bomber
murderers R out in Brooklyn I mean well
and and and his men uh were essentially
divided right there was this this they
were motivated to attack the United
States by one are stationing a troops in
Saudi Arabia two in order to bomb Iraq
from 1990 all the way through okay
through the entire Clinton years and
then support for Israel and their in
their occupations of Palestine and at
that time of Southern Lebanon as well as
support for all the dictatorships in the
region so even though Bill Clinton was
backing them in Kosovo and in cnia they
were still coming for us anyway he was
using them but he wasn't buying their
loyalty and so I'm not like a 9911
truther here saying the CIA had them
attack us that's not right but what
happened was they were too clever by
half just like Netanyahu they think
they're so smart we're going to back
these terrorists and then I'll tell you
I got I got these great uh quotes for
you guys okay this one is from the
American Pentagon in the years before
September 11th they said terrorism is a
small price to pay
for being a
superpower okay and what they were
thinking was come on somebody sets off a
truck bomb at an embassy in Africa or
something who cares we get to rule the
world okay here's a quote just like that
Libby that you can find from from
Benjamin Netanyahu addressing the
leaders of his party the
lud and he's talking about we anyone who
wants to thwart the establishment of a
Palestinian state has to support bolster
ing
Hamas in Gaza hey because they will
never deal but then he said we control
the height of the flame right it's that
same Imperial arrogance of the Bill
Clinton years that we can use these
people to keep things the way we want
them whether to fight our enemies or to
divide and conquer our subject peoples
but then what are they going to do right
in fact one more quote was from
uh a female Israeli soldier who warned
her Superior officers that Hamas is
training they're obviously training hard
they're preparing something and her boss
one sec her boss told her breaking news
break new their punks they won't do
anything NBC Boston is reporting that uh
the main the Le and Main shooter Robert
Carter has been located and is dead oh
damn where is he well good uh they I
don't know I'm just looking at it right
now this is uh the man suspected in
Wednesday's Massacre that killed 18
people in Leon Maine has been found dead
sources told NBC Boston investigators
Friday night Robert car was the subject
of days long of a days long manhood that
followed mass shootings at the Justin
Time Recreation bowling alley and
mimin Bar and Grill schmeg schmies all
right you're from New Hampshire you
should know how to pronounce things it's
it's literally schans I know it's very
weird it'smy anyway um specific details
are not available immediately but the
source told bc1 Boston investigators
that there is no longer a threat in
Maine as card has been located and is
deceased and that is literally just
popped up like five minutes ago I just
wanted to say you know because we we
talk a lot about this deep history with
the Middle East and US involvement and
it kind of feels like uh a lot of the
conversations I've had I'm always just
like someone will make a bunch of points
about well there you know Libby says
these people hate us and then you're
talking about these these operations and
I'm just like
would we would we not benefit from not
being involved like is it better for us
we just totally not be involved 100% And
so when I hear a lot of like moral
arguments well like what they're doing
this and they're doing this and then you
know the Israel Palestine stuff
specifically I'm kind of like my
response is I'm America I don't know why
we're arguing with the morality of
foreign Nations that are in a
generational conflict when we we should
be helping our people the answer is the
answer is because America is the world
Empire Tim and this is a huge
contradiction right this is the new
world our ancestors came here so they
can mine their own business and be free
and yet America came out on top at the
end of the second world war the rest of
the industrialized world was burnt to
the ground and so America had what half
the GDP of the planet and then they took
full advantage and they created a world
Empire they Justified it in the name of
containing the Soviet Union and then
when the Soviet Union ceased to exist 30
years ago what' they do quit and go get
a real job no they went and they
expanded to the Middle East they
expanded into Eastern Europe and they
picked a fight with al- Qaeda and they
picked a fight with Russia and now here
we are let me same as they expanded by
the way you guys are such China Hawks on
here but who started the China pivot
that was Barack Hussein Obama and
Hillary Clinton who said now's time to
pick a fight with China that was their
policy I just want to you know my my
view and it's probably naive it's
probably ignorant whatever but my view
is a tremendous opportunity of the fall
of Soviet Union for trade agreements and
not war right to to to say hey we're you
know you look at what's going on in
Eastern Europe and we keep hearing from
The Establishment press and from the
neocon neol unip party that it's an
unprovoked invasion of Ukraine and
Russia oh come on NATO expansion that's
my book is called provoked it's about
how they provoked it but at the very
least if you want to make the argument
that uh you know I was in Ukraine at the
start of the protests which which
eventually turned into the ating of
yanukovich and in the city I talk to
many random people and what did I find
they were very Pro proe and the when I
talk to them they say that what I what I
was generally told by a lot of
ukrainians was you know Russia wants to
re create this fed this Trade union they
want Ukraine to be a part of it Ukraine
many ukrainians don't trust Russia
obviously because sov wasn't even that
long ago so a lot of the older folks are
really concerned and entering the EU is
a major economic lift up and the shenen
Zone A lot of people want to move and so
that's where where we're going
that is that is all geopolitical dispute
and conflict which results in escalated
conflict the idea that there's no
provocation uh uh what the media keeps
saying is just absurd as as long as our
military alliances are expanding in a
region there is cause for conflict
you're absolutely right and look this
isn't just hindsight okay this is what
all the Paleo conservatives said 30
years ago Pat Buchanan and you know
Scott McConnell and all the guys who
were like the refugees from the George
HW Bush Republican party at that time
Ron Paul ran for president in 1988
saying we need to completely back out of
the old world alt together and was
absolutely right and and you know what
happened HW Bush took full advantage he
lied to the Russians he knew the plan
was to expand NATO and they lied to the
Russians and made them believe that they
wouldn't expand NATO just to get them
out of the way you know what I love
you're obviously familiar they GL us
into Iraq War I as well you're obviously
familiar with the liberal economic order
sure so you know Ian brings that up
quite a bit and we've pulled up the
Council on Foreign Relations website
outlining the liberal economic order and
plainly stating is said after World War
II the fears of expanded uh war and
nuclear Annihilation led to this idea of
the liberal economic order which is a
soft way of saying American Empire
military bases everywhere the American
World Police and it's it's an
impossibility uh naturally what you're
doing is creating something that becomes
the massive Target you the the us never
had the capability of suppressing the
rise of any other economic power though
they try it doesn't happen and now we're
staring at the fourth turning World War
II whatever you want to call it and it's
my favorite part is you get to the point
where you get HW Bush saying what was
his quote we we can begin to see a new
world order mhm now you get a bunch of
people complaining about the idea of the
New World Order which literally is a
reference to an expansion upon the CFR
the liberal economic order into a new
version of it which is American World
Police Etc the media Runs Out full speed
screaming the conspiracy theory of the
New World Order and what I think happens
is a lot of people fall victim to this
there's a legitimate concern over over
powerful interests internationally
corporate interests and their and their
uh uh their um vassals in government to
create and maintain the liberal economic
order and their new version of it what
happens then is the media because these
people are easily they're stupid and
they're evil for not not every single
one but a lot of them they will take the
legitimate story of the liberal economic
order pull the most absurd claims off
the internet create this psychotic
conspiracy theory and then say anybody
who's saying this believes the crazy
conspiracy theory yeah to try and
discredit the idea that there are people
who are actually calmly and rationally
saying you know the thing you've been
doing for a long time about trying to
set up military bases everywhere to be a
World Police I think it's a bad idea
that's going to get us all killed they
say what he actually believes that
lizard people have set up a base in the
Denver Airport and he's insane don't
listen to him right look you're right
and look the the New World Order when HW
Bush said it what he meant was the era
of the American Empire and no one can
oppose us now as he put it what we say
goes and when they say now they call it
the liberal rules-based International
order that's again it's the American
Empire and but the conspiracy theory is
the opposite actually the conspiracy
theory is that ultimately they're going
to create a one world federal government
under the UN that will then conquer the
United States and we'll have Chinese
troops everywhere and it'll be like red
Don we all be enslaved and this is the
thing which it's good for getting
right-wingers interested in foreign
policy and how dangerous all this stuff
can be because look ultimately you know
the John burchers were the big pushers
of the New World Order conspiracy and
the lesson that they were preaching
basically was the only way to destroy
America is to turn it into an
overextended Empire now from their point
of view it was all deliberate it was all
treason to bring us down but forget that
just stick to the point
the only way to bring down America is to
turn it into an overextended World
Empire and you could carpet bomb us with
h bombs but then there's nothing to take
overwise the only way to do it is to
drive our national debt up till the
dollar breaks the Roman Empire which is
what we're doing right now so it doesn't
have to be a conspiracy it's bad policy
it's suicide it it we we a lot of people
like to talk about the Roman Empire and
what caused it to be ripped apart and
there are similarities there I history
doesn't rhyme it repeat doesn't repeat
it rhymes and so a lot of people are
drawing parallels to all these other
historic events and some people be like
no no no it's not like this one it's
like this one it's not the Roman Empire
it's more like you know the bullsh vict
in Russia and I'm like guys it's a
little bit of all of them and that's a
big problem yeah it's us hey look so
let's get back to talking about the
Palestinians here for a second
because you know people use Hamas and
Palestinians interchangeably here like
all these people are guilty of the
things that Hamas did but I mean Tim the
reason I'm here right now is because I'm
still not over Waco okay oh dude I went
there I went there last year so my dad's
from there but but like if according to
the logic of the people who want to bomb
Gaza right now I'm responsible for Waco
because somehow I didn't prevent Bill
Clinton from becoming president and now
it's okay to kill me and my family
because of the things that Bill Clinton
did that was the logic that Osama Bin
Laden invoked in his letter to America
in 2002 he said you pay your taxes you
vote in elections and boy especially you
Americans always bragging and boasting
about how self-governed you are there's
more Nuance than so then he said he had
the right to kill us which was in fact
he was paring Bill Clinton and meline
Albright who said that they had the
right to kill innocent Iraqis in order
to force them to rise up and overthrow
Saddam Hussein it's the same sick
morality we think the price is worth it
as mine Albright said to kill innocent
people to do what we want to get what we
want I suppose the uh uh the big
question then becomes
what do we
do what like that that's why I brought
up that maybe we we we as Americans we
first and foremost the United States
should adopt an absolutely
non-interventionist foreign policy 100%
100% and that means telling the Israelis
you guys are on your own and this goes
back to a point that you raised I think
before we went on the air what happens
to Israel without the UN is be fine
without the United States Israel would
be better off without the United States
as you guys have noticed everything
America touches turns to fire and I just
didn't say a bad word did you say better
off Israel no Israel would be better off
without the US yes because look they're
plenty well enough armed to take on any
neighboring nation state which they're
friends with Jordan and friends with
Egypt they bomb Syria with impunity once
or twice a month for a decade straight
now hez Bala has enough of a force
probably to keep them out I mean not in
a fulls scale war in a fullscale war is
completely destroy him but hbal has no
real offensive force that threatens
Israel so they're perfectly safe right
has I thought who's perfectly safe
Israel is perf from from foreign nation
states I'm saying now is well that was
the question right so I'm just trying to
clarify yeah yeah um so but by having
America there it's like being a banker
on Wall Street and knowing that Allen
greenpan is going to bail you out right
it's called a moral hazard in economics
they called it the green span put right
and what happens is if if you're a
banker and you know that the FED is
going to bail you out then you can make
all kinds of lousy loans and it doesn't
matter cuz you're going to be made whole
it's the same for like a bratty little
kid in the neighborhood who likes to be
a bully and pick fights because he knows
he has an older brother that's going to
bail him out if he gets into a fight
with somebody that he can't handle right
and so this is the same kind of
situation with Israel if America did not
well look at just the current situation
if Joe Biden didn't sail aircraft
carriers right in there and tell
Hezbollah you better not think about it
and tell the government in Iraq you
better keep your militias under control
and all that Israel would already have
to scale back their ambition here right
by showing is perfectly safe or Israel
would have to scale back there what do
you mean yes I'm I'm saying that the
more violence that Israel commits and
over the decades the more they refuse to
deal in good faith with the people in
the Gaza Strip and the West Bank the
Palestinian people the worst situation
that they're in the fact liby that we're
having this conversation in
2023 means that netanyahu's policy is a
terrible failure 100% no different than
if it had been Bill Clinton's thirdd
term on September 11 should Israel do
right now and what should they have done
on October 8th well on October 8th I
think they were still chasing the the
terrorists back into Gaza but look right
now they have the place completely
surrounded okay they've called up
300,000 reserves this is essenti I have
an Israeli friend again an army veteran
who fought in the 2006 War he says this
is like Waco right now they're
completely surrounded who is the Gaza
Gaza is they're completely under siege
and yes Hamas is bad and yes Kesh is bad
but there's also a bunch of innocent
people in there and so just wait them
out you got all the time in the world
there's no reason that you have to go in
there like this and you know Daryl ER
are you are you guys familiar with
martyr made the podcast Mar this is my
good friend Daryl Cooper he's so smart
about this we had him on I'm he talked
about how for decades for decades the
way that the Israelis dealt with
terrorism in the territories would they
go in there and pick them off one at a
time you don't have to do a big war like
this how do they kill shik Yasin they
just found him in his car and dropped
one bomb on them I'm not saying that was
okay but I'm saying all other things
being equal
the Israelis can pick off the leadership
of Hamas one at a time no
problem because again this is not some
foreign Nation this is an Indian
Reservation it's under their control
this is this is where I always come back
to it's like I I see you guys we're
having an argument over a foreign
nation's capabilities of defense and I'm
just like you want to talk about America
I'm just curious what what he was what I
know I know know I'm not I'm not casting
shade I'm saying I think a lot of this
debate that end in politics reverts back
to the normative position of we we as
the United States are concerned and
involved in Foreign Wars and I'm kind of
like you want to talk about Burma
Myanmar you like we right I don't yeah
CU we're not in on that one right let
not being on any of them that's right
look I look I toally is so closed it's
hard to get any information out of since
1948 hundreds of thousands of people
have died in the region 12,000 this year
and talk about ethnic cleansing so
there's one there's one thing that I
want we're not involved in it about well
not only that it's not it's not just
that it's the Tim this goes to a point
that you make a lot you you frequently
say that the left doesn't have an
ideology that that's coherent and to
some degree I think you're right but I
really think that the left broadly is is
just anti-west right they're anti-
capitalist they're anti-america and any
I anything that's going on that is
pushing back against Western society
which is why like the people that are
pro Palestine that are very anti-israel
when they if they're if they're leftists
the reason is because Israel is a is a
ostensibly a democracy in a western
style country and so it falls in line
with the push back against the West
whole de colonization thing I I also
think it's it's because you want to
destroy the United States from within
and so we have foreign influence through
social media and algorithm yeah and and
you mentioned they're all anti-west I'm
like well we're we're being gutted from
within purpose we started this show with
a massive protest at what Grand Central
Station of American Jews who are against
this stuff I'm not saying every I'm not
saying I'm not saying everyone is SC I'm
saying that the people that are that are
like I'll tell you I'll tell you Phil
look I'm not pushing back against what
you said no no no it's fine I just
saying want to shout out to uh alad
eliahu who's covering this right now
he's a we're texting you right now he's
elad is uh um in-house Bolton bro
neoconservative self true he is but he
he does a really great job asking
questions he doesn't attack people he
asks them honestly what they think and
believe and lets them answer Co and you
know he's down here covering it we're
we're big fans of work I mean people
ought to ask themselves cuz look these
Jews almost all American Jews are
basically like Center left liberals
they're not leftist communist
revolutionary hate America whatever this
and that they're liberal Democrats
almost all of them right like 85 90% or
something like that um they don't want
to destroy Western Civilization the
reason they're sticking up but forget
the college kids don't mean anything
we're let's not spend another minute
talking about college kids tonight we're
talking about what actually matters in
the world here okay and what's Happening
Here is these Jews are sticking up for
the Palestinians because they're being
treated unfairly right if you go back to
England versus Ireland you'd see English
stick up for the Irish you didn't see
the Irish take the english's side why
not well because Ireland wasn't
occupying England it was the English who
were the occupying power and who were
brutally oppressing innocent civilians
and so you'd have English from time to
time saying geez guys this isn't right
why would you have millions of American
Jews opposed to the system in Israel
right now well a bunch of the because
it's wrong funded by the same well
funded nothing same groups that fund the
splc and a bunch of other
heavy yeah the JV
you know what what it really is is what
it is is American Jews caes American
Jews are liberals and they believe in
civil rights and the fact is the
Palestinians have no civil rights and no
civil liberties whatsoever they would be
slaves is that the Israelis don't want
them they just want rid of them but they
have no rights at all and these people
know that that is wrong and they're
upset about also had Shabbat with
Rashida Talib after she said that um she
gets what warm fuzzy feeling when she
thinks about the Holocaust is that what
she said she said something like that
she said something very similar I can
find it I I I I I am not a fan uh I'm a
fan of the sentiment of we don't want
civilian deaths but I just keep coming
back to the you know I I would refer I
refer to it as Israel derangement
syndrome because for some reason this
cause for a lot of people is Paramount
despite not being us despite all the
other conflicts in the world Tim as you
know we're implicated in every bit of
this our our government is implicated in
every bit people do not get as mad about
Sudan I wrot Sudan I wrote a book about
the Iranian Revolution the Iran Iraq war
the 80s Afghan war Iraq War I Iraq war
one and a half Iraq War II Somalia Libya
Syria and Yemen and there's some
Palestine in here and I'm writing a book
about Russia right now and why are
16-year-olds prot chanting in the
hallways of their school free free
Palestine do you think these these kids
who cares I mean well I I think the
media abolish government school then I
already want
that this is my point why why why does
it always like I'm gonna when I was a
kid we said kill them all nuke Baghdad
whatever which is worse I'm I'm just
continually at the point where I'm like
y'all can go protest for any country in
the world you want I don't care they're
not us in Marjorie Taylor Green's
resolution that she brought before the
house to have Rashida Talib censored
censured she said said Talib said the
Holocaust gave her a calming feeling
okay I want an original Source on
that I watched I watched the video like
she actually said that there's I swear
to God there's a video clip of it she
said it it was never heard of that she
wasn't like it was it was it was in it
was a broader context but the overall
2019 yeah the overall point was she's
like I have a c I had a calming feeling
I never voted for a democrat in my life
so I don't give a damn about that I did
and then she said she stood behind her
comments 2019 let me tell you
guys College Communists are bad on
everything about Flint Michigan College
Communists are bad on communist College
Communists are bad on everything the
squad is bad on everything but so what
does that have to do with what we're
really talking about here right like
look why would it be that George HW Bush
and James Baker 30 years ago thought it
was so important to try to negotiate a
Palestinian state
why is it that 20 years
ago saying is that there should be a
Palestinian State yes yes I'm saying
maybe that's why they maybe they have
the same reasons as you for wanting to
establish it that's that's what I'm
saying say they've been trying for a
very long time right and but so this is
what I'm saying is people act
like I'm paraphrasing I'm I'm I'm
plagiarizing martyr maid here okay he
says people act like the Palestinians
are this volcano like everything is fine
and then every once in a while while
this volcano erupts and there's this
violence but the thing is everything's
not fine the thing is these people are
under total occupation for longer than
the Soviets occupied Eastern Europe they
have no rights whatsoever that is why
James Baker was willing to go to the mat
to try to force a Palestinian State 30
years ago that's why Coen Powell went to
the mat and lost 20 years ago is because
and what happened was the
neoconservatives which who are the
neoconservatives they're the Vanguard of
the Israel Lobby is who they are and
they convinced Bush that the road to
Damas the the uh road to Jerusalem runs
through Baghdad first we do aaq War II
then we're in the position of strength
to force the Palestinians to bow down to
our wishes how did that work
out did you do you I'm not going to
answer we got to go to super chats but I
want you to finish that thought I know
if you were done go we're we're going to
go to super chats pal lost so smash that
like button subscribe to uh Channel
share the show with your friends Friday
night ladies and gentlemen we're going
to read your super chats which of course
are oh it's Israel Palestine so
contentious I'm I'm so excited Clint
Torres says howdy people Tim today you
gave a master class in dealing with the
delusional I swear you deserve an
honorary PhD in Clinical Psychology this
morning was an awesome conversation with
Jen yuger and uh for those that watched
you probably noticed there was one point
of contention when I began discussing
George Floyd and ammed Arbury uh Jen got
very heated about that one did not want
to to hear any arguments or Point said
it was racist and uh I I felt it's we're
better off focusing on on on Solutions
and ideas and try to pull away from what
I thought was devolving things into uh
an irrational WWE style drama fight but
uh that was probably the only only point
at which I felt like I got to that point
um I see a lot of people are saying that
I'm very patient or whatever and uh it's
a mix there's a lot of people who want
me to just tell him he's wrong no matter
what every single step of the way
whenever I think he's wrong but the
purpose of a show like this is I'm
interviewing the guy and asking him what
he thinks so he can try and articulate
it and I can get the best honest
understanding but more importantly when
Jen comes out and starts saying that
it's racist to to bring up the facts of
the case in ammed Arbury that's for you
guys to watch it's not to see me come
out and say something like let's you
know it's not for me to argue with and
be like no how dare you say that you
know you think you can come in here that
serves nobody that's just people eating
popcorn and laughing at a fight I want
you to hear what what Jen's argument is
and then you figure out if you agree or
disagree and I think often when it comes
to a lot of these arguments
they'll say things that you'll find hey
that's actually not a well wellth
thought out thing to say or maybe you
agree with them but that's the point is
to to have them say it there was a uh
that's a really smart point to make well
conservatives were trying to get this
Pro Palestine event canceled at uh in
Texas and I immediately tweeted like no
way if you if you are concerned these
people are pramas whatever let them
speak right and then take those videos
and share them let them have their event
like with the drag queen stuff what you
mean with kids no not with kids but like
when they
they do the or whatever yeah all right
all right but anyway we'll read some
more uh RJ McDougle Heim says damn so
close wrath says maybe maybe maybe not
you guys were not first Matthew Hammond
says can Lauren Southern do a
documentary on coid lockdowns and
businesses that closed call it
non-essential oh that would be cool one
of the people she interviews should be
the wife of the former guest Gary uh B
nerd rodic I can't pronounce his P name
buckler um what I will say is we did
this documentary with Lauren Southern
we're really excited but uh Lauren is
going to be working with tenet so I
don't know uh to what degree what
documentary did you do with Lauren we
did one it's called infringed it is a
exploring yeah red yeah yeah yeah so uh
Lauren being Canadian she takes a look
at uh gun control she has this like
adventure looking at gun it's awesome
it's coming out uh November 7th great so
we're super excited for it it was
supposed to come out Fourth of July and
then there was legal stuff can we get a
can we get a screener so we can write
about it in advance and absolutely we'll
drop it when you're you
and uh it's I'm told it's exciting and
fun and Lauren CHS a lot of guns and we
like guns so that's awesome but yeah
that's coming up soon and then I'm also
just really excited I don't know if you
guys saw the the the trailer that was
released by tenet media it's a it's a
we're doing a super group all right so
uh Benny Johnson Dave Rubin me uh uh
Taylor Hansen it's Taylor right I always
get his name wrong yeah Lauren Southern
I think this uh Matt Christianson I'm
super excited about Matt Christensen
shout out to Matt Christenson he's
amazing love his work um but we're
basically you know putting together the
super group so it's a bunch of various
projects that are coming together and I
think it's it's wildly beneficial but I
don't want to say too much because you
know I there's other people involved too
but the culture War show will be moving
uh there there's a lot more going on but
uh super excited for this Matt Christian
is I didn't know that he was involved in
ten he's great I really like his his
streams I that's awesome you know that
that was like you know when this this
this super group is coming together and
I'm like yeah yeah and they're like
Matt's involved I was like oh really I
was like okay well you know now send me
send me let me know what's going on and
then I talk to everybody who's involved
and I think it's it's it's really really
smart it's one of the smartest moves in
New Media in my opinion nice yeah uh I
don't want to I don't want to get into
too much detail until they do their
formal launch and everything put the
trailer out but there's a lot I could
elaborate on why I think it is really
really smart there are people saying
things like Tim you're supposed to be
independent what are you doing it's like
yes yes Tim cast is an entirely separate
company we did a deal with them so we
could we could it's it's a multi-front
uh battle in the culture War but I I
really do think there's there's a lot
more to be said and I'll save it for
when they do all their big announcements
and they want to you know I don't want
to step anyone's toes but it's going to
be it's going to be epic so it's really
really cool stuff I think it's going to
amplify the the the the reach of many
people involved it's going it's a
tremendous move I think in winning the
culture War uh we've all we all talked
with a lot of people about the strategy
and stuff I'm really excited for this so
uh let's read some more Shane H Wilder
says great job with the culture War I'm
glad it was a civil discussion even if I
still disagree with Jen regardless these
conversations need to be had keep it up
I think the most important thing that
came out of that was the question over
uh who has a right to be president and I
know a lot of conservatives will have
the the more immediate response of you
have to be born in this country or born
to American uh parents and my point was
Chinese Communist uh party members
having a surrogate in California give
birth to their son who is now a natural
born citizen who within an hour of being
born is flown back to China who is
raised in China and then a loyal CCP
member comes to the United States and
wants to be president that doesn't make
sense so the line isn't just if you were
born here because there's issues that we
have to deal with right now with people
coming here just to you know having
their kids just to be born here so they
get these rights and access if so the
question is what should the test in
restriction B if we're going to have one
Jen made interesting points I don't
completely agree he argued the 14th
amendment has already determined you can
be president even if you weren't born
here I well I I don't think the Supreme
Court sides with them but he's saying
he's going to win and all that stuff he
has to say that you know to be fair he's
making the he's making the argument but
you know my my point was who would you
rather have uh as president someone who
is a Chinese Communist Party member and
official who was born in California
spent three days here and then was
raised in China or Danes Doza well I'd
rather have denesh but he wasn't born
here so he can't be president sorry you
get the CCP member but he's very smart
but I don't know why anyone would vote
for the C I don't know why those are the
only options like it's not I never could
figure out why country at 300 million
people we got to settle for the scum
that run the highest office because in a
country that has so much opportunity
like America people that are skilled and
that go do actually good things why
aren't you running a come on you know
what I
am I'm a great advisor to libertarian
party presidential candidates that's
what I am and you know what I screwed up
I forgot to say during the main part of
the show I got an article on antiwar.com
today the spotlight article it's full of
quotes in fact if anyone's collecting
these quotes it's your ultimate resource
for quotes of Benjamin Netanyahu and his
men explaining why they like Hamas
ruling the Gaza Strip so they don't have
to deal in good faith with the
Palestinians on the West Bank and I got
a A list of quotes this long it's a
spotlight on antiwar.com right now
here's here's an important question um
and and with respect because we're huge
fans of Dave Smith why isn't Dave Smith
running for the for for president I have
no comment on that he's cuz he's got a
wife and kid that his kid had like had I
don't know for sure that like it's not
like I know talk to him but he's got a
his kid had has a heart condition I get
it I get it I I mean no disrespect when
I ask my point is running for president
is very very very hard you have to have
something deeply wrong with you Dave
Smith would have to be like my family is
not important to decide to run for
president oh I don't think that's true I
mean especially as a Libertarian you
could do a half-ass job and still be you
know the all right Dave where you at the
the problem that we've had in the
libertarian part for a very long time
since Harry Brown is We've Ended up
we've essentially well bad Nar was I
don't know we we
have presidential candidates who don't
understand the philosophy and don't know
how to talk about it and don't know you
know we have Bob bar and Gary Johnson
and that's right you know I'll tell you
a story where where were you to whisper
in his ear I'll tell you where I was I
wrote Gary Johnson a memo this long
about Syria the night before that
happened are you kidding me I swear to
God and and which was all about what it
was all about Gary Barack Obama is
backing Al Qaeda in Syria right now bro
like I was hitting him with some good
stuff only making me hate him more and I
swear this is what he answered me he
answered me back libertarian
thanks right not like wait a minute can
I call you and ask you some followup
questions cuz this godamn Gary Johnson
but wait wait listen listen the the
funny thing about the Aleppo moment is
you know what Trump would have said oh
no look Aleppo is interesting I know a
lot of people are talking about it but
focused on
jobs he would have pretended to know
exactly and that the more important
thing is jobs and then you well he's
right the more important thing is job
and what's so funny is what's so funny
about that too is that if he had known
what he was talking about if he cared at
all to know about the Syria War he could
have had such a great fight with them
cuz you want to talk about Aleppo I'll
tell you about Aleppo that's where
Barack Obama backs the suicide bomber
head chopper murderers of Al Qaeda and
where the secular
dictator with the clean shaven chin in
the three-piece suit who protects the
rights of Christians and Shiites and
other minorities in the country is
trying to save that City from America's
mercenary terrorist forces and were they
what yeah exactly and what were they
saying at the time they were saying that
Assad is committing genocide Assad is
attempting to murder every last man
woman and child in his own country and
luckily al- Qaeda is there the moderate
Rebels are trying to stand up to him and
prevent him from accomplishing this but
then what happened just after that
within a couple of months after that not
even a few weeks after that the Assad
government finished retaking that town
the jihadists all got on buses to the
idlib province and then what
happened they had Christmas and all the
Christians came back wow and all the
civilian population of Aleppo came back
the city was saved by Bashar al-assad
from the real genocidal murderer Barack
Hussein Obama all right and Benjamin yah
Sparky wire says Tim's unhinged
Financial advice sleep in the park with
$5,000 in your backpack you got to risk
it for the biscuit sorry if you're not
willing to do uh uh uh to take those
risks you don't win that's just the way
it's going to be you gotta you got to
bet big to win big now look I I'll in
all honesty in all seriousness I
wouldn't recommend anybody do what I do
in terms of uh risk and you know I got
you take a lot of wacky rks and you do a
lot of wacky things it's all oh I love
doing wacky things that mini Mega you
were going to build here man oh man I
would love to see a map like I don't
want to I don't want to bis merch the
good name of of uh of friends of mine
but I'll tell you afterwards it's more
of a private thing it's it's kind of
just like you know business stuff so
we're but uh uh uh we're we're it's
coming it's just it's somewhere else
okay yeah so I got to tell you I want to
try it but also I'm so Terri oh we got
we have we have a big project with the
new skatepark stuff that we're doing and
we're really really excited so uh I
don't know if we've been posting yet
it's called The Boonies it's the skate
show and project we're doing we're
producing a lot of content but uh my my
my real point I like it yeah Scott next
time you come no matter what you think
bring the skate I'm bringing my board
next time we had a great session last
time after the show it's it's like
midnight I am dead tired and he's like
you have to skate I did a kickflip pivot
on the mini ramp he did do a kickflip
pivot on the mini ramp like that's not
bad you know he's got he's got a mean
hard flip well he showed us this video
earlier but I seen with my own eyeballs
a mean hard flip and what do you call
that hang T hard flip I love that that's
awes almost HT hard flip light flip I've
done them but uh I landed an Oli blunt
and I still remember telling myself do
not bail these boys are looking at you
feet on grip tape Horton so uh as for
the sleeping in a park with a ton of
money what I will say is to varying
degrees you must determine the amount of
risk you are willing to take and I would
not recommend anyone take any risk if
someone comes to me and says I want to
go report from turkey and Istanbul
during mass protests I would say don't
ask me because I'll tell you not to do
it why I will not be responsible for the
risks you decide to take because I'm not
you that being said I take a whole lot
of crazy risks and boy do they pay off
so uh weren't you there for the Kyan
coup in ' 05 or something like that what
I'm not that
old I was in the GUI Park protests but I
know to get out of War like and I have
no problem saying this I there I have no
illusions of grandeur when when civil
unrest results in war I'm I'm gone 3
hours before that happens and I'm like
you need military veterans to be
reporting from these locations you need
people with actual War experience cuz
it's it's about two things I got no
problem risking my own life but I cannot
be responsible for someone else's and
I've been in some serious conflict stuff
where they have strapped people to my
ankles and I'm like I have to keep this
person alive now now I am not the person
for that job I am not a medic I am not a
first responder I'm not a soldier I I
would not be able to handle that I have
no problem running and jumping over
walls and breathing in tear gas and
bullets are flying and I'm hitting the
deck but the moment you put someone with
me who doesn't have any capabilities and
I know if I abandon them that I I was in
Venezuela they they're their National
Guard they're shooting at people Crow uh
uh so they they had been shooting people
in in the past so when these protests
happened they weren't shooting where I
was I don't believe when something
snapped between the National Guard and
the students everyone runs I yell to my
crew move now run and I run and I look
back and they're just standing there
staring at the National Guard with
rifles and their Mar and I'm like oh my
God oh my God like they're they're going
to die and so I was just I lost it I
said guys we're leaving I will not be
here to pick up your remains like people
are being shot and killed in this place
we it wasn't in war zone it was civil
unrest with live ammo those that's
that's my limit and I'm like I couldn't
imagine being in in act actually in
Syria or Afghanistan or like that I
could not handle that and so that for me
was like if you if you can't do this if
you're not trained I'm sorry I am not
skilled enough to be able to to to to be
a fixer for you guys and I and I and I
and I think about there are a lot of
journalists I know who are dumb as a box
of rocks and they'll get some like you
know Iraq war veteran to be their
security head and I'm like what a job
yeah that's I'm like yikes man I
wouldn't put anyone in that position
myself my my own dumb journalist self I
would when when the security guys when I
would be they would make us do the
security things like uh coordination and
prep I'd uh I'll give you a better story
I was in Brazil interviewing uh the bopy
I think it was the B it could have been
the the the car or whatever it's called
SWAT cops they had this Mock flla and
they're they're explaining how they go
in to deal with the the gang members and
the cartels and all that stuff it was
like their own cop City it's it's no
it's not a cop City it's a fake flla
it's a training center that's designed
to be like a FLL and we're on the top of
a building and I and he's explaining
like you know it's very near corridors
and I said what do you do now you're up
here the guy jumps and he goes he smiles
and he just he he he grabs the wall and
he jumps down and then I jump down right
after him and he's like yeah and he
gives me a he gives me a high five like
I just jumped off a building with this
guy so he's like i' I've had meetings
with security guards and I'm like I've
been skateboarding for 20 years and
they're like okay good so when when I
tell you you move you'll be quick I get
it and then you have the other
journalists who are morbidly obese and
don't know what gunshots sound like and
have and they're like all right like
yeah but we got we got to read some more
we got to read some more but my my point
ultimately there is if someone comes to
me and says Tim I'd like to report for
you in the Middle East I'd say nope
because I can't be responsible for you
uh a lot of news organizations will not
allow you they will not hire you it
won't happen this is why they do hire
military veterans so if you're like ha
Tim said sit in the park with five grand
I'm like oh bro I I've done crazier
things than that I mean come on I'm like
I'm driving into active riots and and
and people shooting at each other that's
well way crazier than carrying a bunch
of money in your pocket uh but you got
to figure out the amount of risk you're
willing to take to get the biscuit you
got to risk it for the biscuit skate is
that skateboarding thing or is it I
don't know people saying skateboarding I
never heard that phrase until right now
risk it for the biscuit but I like it
it yeah so I think we just had some
skaters here dude did a kick flip blunt
kick flip it's like you got to risk it
for the I know I'll show you the video
I'll tell you this there's a vert ramp
going up um somewhere in
Texas that's going to be 12 feet with
extensions with pool coping it's going
to be 150 ft wide half a football field
wide vert ramp going in saving my my
legs and my elbows for that one we got
to read more Super chats we got to read
more Super chats Logan Culver says Scott
do you have a photographic memory your
ability to pull up all this info is
amazing uh yes I do have a photographic
memory I can um my real advant one of my
real advantages you know when I was a
boy uh third grade uh my hero was
Encyclopedia Brown and his he the the
crime solver and his thing is he
remembers everything he reads and that's
that's really my talent and I um I can I
kind of picture the I can I can remember
the colors and the shape of the website
really helps me remember where I read
what and when and that kind of thing is
this Dom says general Clark wanted to
attack Russian military in Kosovo James
Blunt and his Co refused Clark's orders
to attack a Russian control airport yeah
so this is what I was mentioning earlier
about the World War I there Clark would
have started World War III in the 90s
he's a warmonger that's right so so when
he says James Blunt this is the singer
um who I'm not familiar with his songs
but I think he's like a real famous guy
right an English singer yes James he was
a colonel yes you're beautiful guy it
gets yes yes that's the guy that's the
guy okay and then it gets better it gets
better Wesley Clark ordered James Blunt
to take his men and seize the Pristina
airport but um after the Russians took
it and the Russians weren't supposed to
take it but they went in there and they
got the Pristina airport Clark ordered
blunt to take the airport and then guess
who intervened and stopped him General
Michael
Jackson what of of the British army what
told you're lying I swear to God we live
in simulation General Michael Jackson
said belay that order blunt and told
just told General Clark I'm not going to
start World War II for you then he
moonwalked across the
exactly and then by the way so Clark
also was in charge of Fort Hood during
Waco it's not Fort Hood anymore isn't it
like whatever Native American for PC but
he was the boss during Waco and general
Shoemaker who was the commander of Delta
Force it's really General Shoemaker who
murdered those people but he was working
for Clark at the time and so those men's
responsibility for that is still to come
due leama says Tim I'd like to see this
man debate historian Benny Morris about
the 1948 War oh boy wouldn't that to see
his ignorance humbled oh that would be
hilarious all I would do is read Benny
Morris to Benny Morris are you kidding
me this guy this guy ought to read what
Benny Morris has written the truth Benny
Morris is I'll have you know we should
do a culture War episode here here's two
things to know about Benny Morris he has
done more he has done more to tell the
truth about what happened during the
nakba to the poor people of Palestine
than probably anyone else he's a
revisionist historian in Israel and then
he also is a total Hawk who says that
they should have finished the job and
cleansed them all all the way out of
there so he's a total Hawk but he's a
honest guy and he has done probably more
for establishing the real truth of what
happened in the Noba than any other
Israeli historian I would love to debate
Benny Morris Tim you you make that
happen for me buddy and I'll SK I'll
bring my skateboard that day well we
should do we should definitely do a
culture War where uh we can we can find
somebody who would like to have a debate
with you uh on all this stuff if you'd
be interested I'm happy to do it' be
great I'm happy to do it I know a lot of
people were hoping that I could debate
Ben Shapiro here but I don't think he'll
show up here sure well here's the issue
uh Ben Shapiro runs a company and hosts
his own show so the idea that it's like
he' go on a neutral thing no it's not
about being neutral it's you know I say
this about Hassan and and Jen Huger I'm
like guys guys if someone's got a
full-time job where they're running a
company and hosting a show the IDE like
if someone said Tim pool why won't you
fly to LA and debate a guy I'll be like
well I'm running a company we got like
40 employees I got a host of my show
disect took I took a week off of writing
my book to read nothing but real stuff
and prepare for this show to come out
here and try to do my best for you guys
um and and I have a lot of jobs no I get
it I get it you know but I think it's
worth it and by the way Shapiro I
challenge you dude I saw you say on Joe
Rogan that you're willing to debate this
issue but I think you're a coward and I
don't think you are man enough well I
got to tell you I don't I don't think
that is conducive to actually having the
conversation with him well except you
know what Gene Epstein already invited
him to debate me for money at the Soho
Forum in New York and he wouldn't do it
and so what ended up happening was i i
instead debated Bill Crystal and into
the ground have you ever seen that it
was aw I debated Bill Crystal and smash
him because Ben Shapiro wasn't man
enough to show up well we we have to
make sure it is the steel manist of
Steel manist uh debates sure so we don't
want to get any half-ass you know agree
not for Bill Crystal Bill Crystal's
garbage he's wrong about everything
everything and look I didn't straw man
Bill Crystal either I don't Straw Men
dude I don't want I don't want to win a
rigged game there ain't no honer in that
we want we want to put the heavyweights
against the heavy weights the only
problem is with debating Ben Shapiro I'm
not sure if I could stop myself from
laughing the whole time he's talking
just from the sound of not going to get
a debate by why why but no but but now
serious why would he debate you if
you're just insulting him okay you know
what he wouldn't already we already
tried this and I told I was actually
very polite at the time and said hey
seriously man I I'd like to discuss this
with you we could do a whole thing and
tried to be very adult about it refused
to respond in any way to Gene Epstein's
offer to have this debate at SoHo Jen
yuger has said some really awful things
about me he's yelled at me in person and
I still like say like I don't insult him
uh I I try to agree with him when I can
and he eventually said you know what
I'll come on Tim's show we talk he came
on because he's running for president
you know but Tim you know that Ben
Shapiro will only debate college girls
who are confused about their gender
identity or some crap he'll make fun of
some little kid he's not he have you
ever seen him debate a grown man about
an actual subject of import of any kind
he go to cont yeah I don't either but
but you know I see him in the right-and
margin on YouTube for some reason every
single day no matter what and it's
always Ben Shapiro destroys 19-year-old
girl who doesn't know the difference
between a girl and a boy okay well
that's you know really impressive I
guess look that's what there's a there's
a Supreme Court Justice that doesn't
know the difference between a girl Fair
Fair Point fair point but no in all
seriousness let's why don't we find
someone who's like sure like very like
top tier I'm happy to do it I'm happy to
do it yeah and look I think this is
something that you guys deal with a lot
when you're dealing with the left is all
these ridiculous accusations of racism
you guys were talking about some of this
a little bit earlier in the show today
but it's the same thing on the right
with the claims about anti-Semitism I
bet you you could probably testify to
this more than any other person or just
as well as me any person involved with
online alternative media can tell you
that anyone who's actually an
anti-semite will tell you that they are
and will try to convince you to also be
and so when you hear right Wingers
throwing around Jew hater and
anti-semite when we're talking about
Israel Palestine that ought to sound as
ridiculous in your ear as when everybody
calls you a racist just cuz you disagree
about the minimum wage or whatever it is
that they're stupid on you know all
right we'll read some more Missy kin
says Tim how did you not want to punch
chank during the culture War interview
today for saying you attract
right-wingers because you look at the
Nuance in each of the high high-profile
police killings I I don't want to hit I
I I don't want to hit anyone ever
sometimes in self-defense you have to
the I think the most I've ever gotten
into saying that I wanted to punch my my
monitor screen or something but you know
I like it's it's about tech but no no no
no listen listen people need to
understand
this Jen performed as I hoped he would
we the first and foremost the most
important thing we AG age on a lot I'm
like if we can be I said what were
youall mostly talking about uh foreign
war I think well I don't know is two and
a half 2 hours and 40 minutes probably
probably a bunch of things but what
stood out to me is I said if we can win
where we agree we should focus on those
things yeah Max Blumenthal Blumenthal
said that and I said if Mitt Romney was
running against with Joe Biden I'd vote
Jen yuger why at least we get Julian
Assange pardon all right and and I can I
I can bet he's not going to start
Foreign Wars now all the other stuff I
think is probably gonna be awful
but if and I say Romney not that he's
running but because he's the example of
that garbage Republican and and Joe
Biden is the garbage Democrat they're
going to screw me over every way and
have War so like if if the best I can
get is is Jen who is is for gun control
and a bunch of woke policy and stuff you
know that's what I wanted to focus on
but but understand when I be when I
began talking about uh George Floyd and
then he lost it I'm like I'm not I'm not
saying it's right or wrong asking you
what is what is the answer to there is a
man behind the wheel of an SUV chewing
on a speedball methamphetamine INF
fentanyl should the police not intervene
he says they should I'm like okay and
when the police do and the man resists
what should they do and he's like I
can't believe you're defending I said
okay well then he's like the most high
Prof profile case I said let's talk
about ammed Arbury I said and he goes oh
you mean when the two racist guys killed
that jogger and I'm like okay right here
this is the point if you don't know the
facts of the case and he's like I can't
believe you would even say this and blah
blah blah but that's the point I want
everyone to see Jen say that Jen wants
everyone to see Jen say that the wager
both of us have made is that I believe
the average person will be repelled by
what he said he believes the average
person will agree and be attracted to
what he said I I'll take my wager I
think what he said was repellent but he
said it because he believes it I'm glad
he did we had a great conversation I'm
not mad about it I'm like thank you for
saying that I'm I'm now going to show my
friends and family and I say this is
what an argument looks like when you try
bringing up the Nuance in a in in in a
in a criminal trial yeah that made me
mad I thought I was I was just really
glad to see the conversation I mean it's
so rare and you guys talked about this
in the interview like it's so rare to
see um people from you know sort of
Divergent political perspectives
actually have a conversation you know
yeah well I I Max Blumenthal came on I
said the he said he said the same thing
he's like we're probably going to
disagree on a lot and I'm like then
let's just win all of the things we can
win on that we want and then go back to
complaining about each other is that is
that fair like I totally agree with that
listen look I'm a Libertarian and so
that means I know that no matter what
like if I die at 85 we're still going to
be a tiny minority of the population of
the country so I can try to recruit as
as many new Libertarians as I can but I
also just want to help the right and the
left to prioritize to be the least worst
right and the left that they could be as
well you know what I mean so the
majority the majority of this country is
anti-war I absolutely agree with that
and especially that it's really changing
on the right unfortunately this Israel
thing has really kind of put thrown a
monkey wrench in the America first right
but only temporarily I think it was
interesting though to hear Mike Johnson
talk about um funding for Israel today
because he at least said that any money
that um he would he would advocate for
to go to Israel would have to come from
somewhere else in the budget from other
from Americans go over I mean he didn't
say that I would ideally say that you
know it would be pulled from different
foreign by the way you know you hang on
Libby asked me a question earlier that I
actually didn't get a chance to answer
but I'll just be real brief about the um
because we talked about 48 a little bit
but just kind of this ongoing narrative
that the Israelis keep trying to give
the Palestinians a state and they always
say no that that's just really not true
and in fact I have a book here that I
was reading today I didn't quite finish
it today but it's uh what really
happened or the secret history of Camp
David in the year 2000 and how Arafat
just took all the blame that they tried
to give him a whole state and he refused
to do it and it's just not true and what
happens is they essentially set him up
to be the rejectionist and then they go
aha see and in fact in the book they
show where Bill Clinton agreed and
promised Arafat if it all falls apart I
promise I won't blame you because you're
right they're being real sticklers about
this that and the other forget the
details for a second but the the deal is
not coming through the Israelis are not
being as as uh generous as as they say
whatever and then when the deal falls
apart they go aha it's all his fault and
we tried to give him a state but he
refused to accept it because you know
how those Arabs are and all this kind of
stuff and then and but just to provide
one footnote for that too is people can
look this up this was a leak from 2011
it was leaked to the guardian and Al
jazer it's called the Palestine papers
was it in the sock J was this part of
the Bill Clinton sock drawer I don't
think so totally separate there there
was some if you're talking about Sandy
Burger stealing document that's a
different thing but but these Palestine
papers reveal that the Palestinian
Authority Under mmud abas has been will
they have just been bending over
backwards to accommodate the Israelis
they've been willing to give up all of
their claims on East Jerusalem they've
been willing to give up all their claims
on all but like the three biggest
settlements that prevent the West Bank
from being contiguous and this kind of
deal and then it's the Israelis who
won't negotiate in good faith and you
can read the Palestine papers that they
really demonstrate this all right the
we're going to wrap it up there
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.net fired for being too good on
Ukraine now he writes for me okay and I
got the the uh world famous and heroic
James board we're about to publish his
book lost rights uh pardon me last
rights the death of American Liberty
we're about to publish Tom Wood's book a
Diary of a psychosis how Public Health
failed US during coid Mania and uh oh
you'll love this one domestic
imperialism nine reasons I left
progressivism by Keith Knight awesome
you're going to love it's so good and
he's just brilliant and then of course
all the bad news in the world at
antiwar.com check out my show the Scott
Horton Show I got 6,000 interviews going
back to 2003 proving that me and my guys
are right about everything and and read
my book enough already time to end the
war on terrorism right on I am Phil that
remains on Twix I am Phil that remains
official on Instagram the band is All
That Remains you can find us on Spotify
on YouTube on Amazon on music on Pandora
you know the internet Scott you were
awesome thank you so much oh and I'm on
Twitter at Scott Horton Show too and
thank you I'm very grateful for you
having me here today oh yeah no anytime
man it's been a bless Libby I'm Libby
Emmons you can find me on Twitter I'm
not cool enough to say Twix uh at Libby
em I know but I I can't make it work and
you can find all the great work we're
doing at the post
millennial.age and I'm surge.com I
rooting for the bux you should too we
can beat the All Blacks we have a better
record than them I think I don't know
have to look into that I'm not really
sure but it's the most important thing
in the world Guys South Africa needs to
win the cup please we need that webis
back uh I'm going to be playing music in
DC later tonight cheers and uh some
point soon we got the music set up too
so I'm telling Phil he's go to he's got
to play some music and uh Dennis Prager
to debate Scott might be good oh I'd do
that we can ask him but you know we'll
figure it out all right everybody thanks
for hanging out and we'll have Clips up
throughout the week and weekend and then
we'll see you on Monday
good